two
oh hello
didn't see you there
welcome to off the rails
it's the a street podcast junior
is ethan kline
[Music]
it is
[Music]
if i could frame that i put that on my
wall
it's a masterpiece my goodness
are you an artist zack i guess you are
what can i say i try
i mean you are an artist you play guitar
well thank you do you have an artist
soul zack
what's that do you have an artist's soul
yeah
i think so i have an old soul the
mustache and the soul patch says you're
an artist i saw a top gun so you know
trying to get on that trend oh where's
that the kind of fish i heard they had
on that but usually people are just
being going for the mustache but
i figured i'd go with the little flavor
saver you know oh i thought you're going
for ron jeremy i know you're going for
frank zappa it was like a frank zappa
cop ron jeremy doesn't have a flavor
saver does he no no
jeremy's in jail isn't that crazy he's a
sick [ __ ] he's down bad
that's nuts that he went to jail though
it's like dang all these old fat creepy
dudes are going to jail
the the scary thing is i i took a
picture with him right before he got
arrested it was like literally a week
before
it was crazy wait do you have that photo
somewhere yeah where's the photo
find the photo well anyway
uh thanks everyone for being here
today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn harry's and stamps.com who we
love so well
quick shout out i'm gonna give a little
showcase here teddy fresh we have a new
collection coming out tomorrow but
here's a t-shirt that i think you all
will love that i'm wearing today heavy
lies the crown and don't doesn't he know
it it's teddy
teddy
uh
louis teddy the eighth
[Music]
yes
there's a specific artist we work with
for these um
illustrations who's like mega talent it
takes some i swear to god six months i
don't really understand why
there you have it
it's good though right
it's worth the wait can i get a can i
get a whale if you think this graphics
awesome
thank you guys what happened to his eye
let's go oh he has an eye patch
and what happened to his eye i don't
know
how should i know
you're your ip he's a cr is he's he's
got to fill out the back story
i don't know what happened he's he's had
a rough life man heavy lies the crown
what's the name of his kingdom
the kingdom of jesus nuts bro chancellor
go off king
was that a sound bite of love laughing
or was that really love laughing i was
really loving it i love it dude i get
you every time with these nuts man it's
awesome
take kills bro with you
yeah so check out teddyfresh.com there's
all kinds of great stuff on the website
now with summer coming up get it get
yourself a nice looking t-shirt
you know what i'm saying
thank you
so today's obviously if you read the
title a huge episode
huge episode
so i'm just going to let the cat out of
the bag here oh we've been trying to get
this guy if many fans of the show know
for
years it's got to be we've we've been in
hot pursuit
of wall-e p
joel biden wake up
and he's calling in today
that's it yeah that's the announcement
it's been a long road
[Applause]
so i have so i have no idea how this
conversation is going to go
i'm don't know how the communication is
going to be
but i mean how long we've been looking
for to get him on the call call it's
been years well it's got to be i tracked
down the original clip here where we
reacted to him on an episode of after
dark doing his thing
oh that's the first time we went
this is the one that started it all
because this showed up on your tik tok
page okay okay okay just like what the
hell and wait did you guys not know
about him
no you introduced oh i discovered while
he played this is a ethan klein
discovery oh how that's good i honor
myself yeah and then but you guys kind
of took the mantle from me especially
you dan you sent it to me
and
uh was like check this out and then we
added to the show and then i went down
the rabbit hole and became a huge wally
p
head
and uh and still am to this day a p head
a wally happy head yeah a p head yeah i
like p head
uh and yeah this was november 2020 so
it has been
what a year and a half that we've been
trying to get this guy
i got to say oh thank you sarah for 10
gifted subs you legend but i will say um
i think this is internet history because
wally p is kind of a
has international recognition and i
don't think he's ever done an interview
or anything like this
um so we are really going to be
unlocking some mysteries here today and
i i can't be uh any more excited about
it yes and just so you know his um sort
of uh
assistant or partner he's this young guy
tony who has been helping him out
um
and helping him make videos and he
helped him set up his youtube channel
and everything he'll be joining us and
when i did a pre-call with him he was
very helpful in um
uh
translating okay interesting so he
speaks wall-e he speaks why he speaks
while he's walian yes yes he speaks
i'm not fluent in wellington but i'm
going to try my best yes
oh we got the photo already zach
yeah seconds before uh tragedy strikes
man you could be his son i know it's
kind of scary oh you're a lot taller
he's quite short eh yeah you know
he was short but a big hog interesting
yeah he used to hang out that's in front
of the rainbow
and the roxy but um that's where he did
his crimes probably no actually like in
the alley there
no he's a sick [ __ ] oh yeah and um he
would go around with his [ __ ]
harmonica
in the rainbow sometimes in the roxy
and just play for people
is that a euphemism for something no you
would actually go around with a
harmonica and play for people and he was
practicing for jail pretty much yeah
right so
shout out to um ron jeremy who is
perishing in behind bars yeah his hair
is all white he's [ __ ] i'm sure they
love his his hog in jail of course yes
so hopefully
he's making the best there yeah he's
disgusting
um
who would have nobody ever saw that
coming with ron jeremy it's just
everywhere like they say
always the first person you suspect it
should be really my my dad took that
picture and he goes up to my dad he's
like hey like and then he comes up to me
he's like hey you got a hot mom just out
of nowhere
i think that right he's like yeah what's
your mom look like
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
why didn't you introduce him
he's like i didn't meet her but i know i
want to [ __ ] her exactly
very odd dude sick [ __ ]
there you have it
fantastic um
so what time is wally calling in
uh two
i'm just gonna sit here silently and
wait okay let's do that i'm so excited
um
oh i guess i should show you guys this
i'll do it really fast
yeah so tomorrow 10 a.m
the new teddy fresh drops if there's
something here that interests you
um is there like a there's like a
million photos in here isn't there maybe
yeah
okay i'm not gonna do that then
lords take some of them down but reverse
fleece color block hoodie this is really
nice
uh
jacket
shirt
shirt
yeah great photo shoot yeah this piece
is really sick yeah the photo shoots are
awesome man necklace bag
okay thank you
all right well
this is what oh anyone who bought
trading cards is shipping next monday
just a quick announcement there all
right let's get into some good stuff you
know in in our last episode on monday
you guys i don't know if you remember
there was like a super low flying
helicopter that scared all of us it was
so gnarly it was joel biden
a whole fleet of
gnarly military-grade
helicopters
they must have flown right over a
building
it was so gnarly but look at this joe
biden travels in style man
i bet he was napping
that's a
fairly safe guess
just the loudest sound you can imagine
he's just
peacefully sleeping
yeah but there you go it was joel biden
wake up
so there you go
if anyone was wondering
a little update on tony
thank you
tony's gofundme by the way up to 15 000
wow that's so nice
[Applause]
let's go
awesome you guys are awesome as you know
oh john scarce donated a thousand what a
guy
scarce is a sweetheart that's scarce
scarce yes that's scarce oh that's so
nice of him
tony's of course is the guy that uh
keemstar ruined his life by um accusing
him falsely accusing him of being a p
word it's one of the most crazy things
i've ever seen on the internet
i was wondering if he was gonna donate
but nope it looks like he's being a
piece of [ __ ] as always
you know i was like i wonder if he's
gonna rise above and drop some cash for
our boy tony no
oh he'll get around to it as soon as he
gets around to doing the charity
fundraiser for the victims of the
buffalo shooting that he promised he
would do oh you have for me
you know about this wait i'm not super
familiar with it because he just put out
a tweet that he was had just got off the
phone with his team
to uh
you have it to put together i mean that
charity thing that's crazy because
always accuse me of faking i don't but
i'll look for it he always accused me of
faking donations and stuff
but you're telling me he maybe didn't
didn't follow through on a pledge there
weird
on a mass shooting too like whoa dude
and there it is to everyone affected
wait dude you're gonna screw over
i think he needs to show proof that he
actually did this
he says i just got off the phone with my
team we'll be doing some type of charity
next week to help out the families of
this tragic mass shooting that happened
today here in buffalo new york i'll
update you as soon as i have more info
that was may 12th man that was almost a
month ago may 14th that's weird nothing
ever may 14th i mean you're really gonna
you're really not gonna do anything
i'm in a sea of slander and lies
you better show some proof that you did
some something bro because this is kind
of shady
wow
wow i think people need to start asking
questions around here big l on my part
he's such a [ __ ] piece of chip
oh people have been asking him and quote
tweets
[Music]
yo for real what happened to this
yo
this is june 2 june 6 keemstar what a
pcg you're not really doing anything huh
[Music]
well well when he got off the phone with
brantley she looked into it and
apparently you can't set up a gofundme
until you're 21 so oh yeah that was the
end of the road
enough yeah that's the team
i talked with my team i talked to my
team my teenage girlfriend and she
wasn't able to figure out how to set up
a gofundme so we're done we're done with
that idea sorry
yeah but it kind of makes sense that he
would like not do that because that
explains why he's always calling me out
for that stuff because you know you see
the world as you are not as it is
and he thinks everyone's a scammer
because well
he's seen the back of his eyelids
wow
um
oh we okay another update this is a big
one the frog army you guys remember this
the guy was who was raising 1.4
million frogs in his backyard dude this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] up
it's so disturbing yeah so the tadpoles
are becoming frogs and
i'm telling you we need we need like
national guard out to this guy's house
because some shit's about to go down
do we know where he lives no i don't he
might not even be in the states i don't
know
and that's true okay let's watch
95 days ago i rescued
one point for million frog eggs and put
them in my pond for a frog army
and now they leaving the pond
and i know a million little frogs
hopping around the garden are you gonna
feed them bro can walk on the grass
anymore
this is the biggest frog army ever but i
kind of regret this now no one can go in
the garden
the full garden and the neighbors are
took over by you regret this now i kind
of regret this
yeah no [ __ ] million tadpoles
people are saying he's in the uk
okay good well at least
at least he's not here quarantined to
the island that's what you get for
brexit
you guys are on your own
frog invasion frog apocalypse yeah wait
so but for real what do little frogs eat
what's their diet consist of insects and
yeah mostly so they're all going to die
of starvation yeah no they this is this
is a horrible thing they're they're
going to all die like 99 of them they
turn the friggin frogs game
back there
what's going on back there
oh
insects how does a little frog eat and
you find insects though are you sure
it's insects can i get a fish fill
answer on that
uh a variety of insects including gut
loaded insects
they're going to start cannibalizing
each other
well yeah they might do that too do you
really just doubt my frog knowledge dude
i oh they're little tiny little how did
these little tiny frogs catch insects
they're gonna go all lord of the flies
well one of them will be lord of the
flies they eat snails and [ __ ] like that
like slow-moving insects i guess they
eat snails a frog
they eat everything yeah
it's weird that more people aren't
talking about this frog situation i
first heard about it at the airport
someone was talking about it that's the
only reason i found it
yo at the airport quick aside a
gentleman daniel bloom
has purchased 50 gift subs
thank you daniel
oh and thank you
for the 50
donation please talk about what's going
on between act man and quantum tv
youtube is basically defending quantum
tv while he gets away with awful things
the act man and many other youtubers
have videos explaining more i will you
know what i'm going to look into that i
don't have enough knowledge about it to
comment on it right now
i saw a tiny little bit about it last
night i saw people quote tweeting i
think it was some ordinary gamer quote
tweeted the act man and said what the
[ __ ] is going on with youtube but
uh let's do a write-up for friday so
yeah we'll look into it more educated
about it on friday
but oh yeah we have a guest on friday so
monday maybe yeah next monday yeah
yeah
friday's gonna be awesome too guys we
have a great week of uh content here for
you baby if you're in the uk man i'm
sorry that uh
you're in the uk i'm sorry this might be
a russian like
a russian uh ploy to destabilize the
i mean [ __ ] they are innovative
this is a great video it's been going
around what do you guys think about this
because i to be honest everyone was
upset about it and i kind of get it okay
i mean the guy's a good employee is what
you're seeing here there's a disney
employee
absolutely
brutally i'll say it was a bit maybe too
brutal
destroying this wedding proposal he
snatches the ring too like bro you
didn't have to snatch the ring that was
pretty gnarly i mean he has no right to
take the ring like what the [ __ ] i've
not actually seen this clip yet and i've
seen all the discourse oh for real i'm
very excited okay so let me give you a
little background
these guys went up on a restricted area
okay
wait who's that girl is she with them
yeah
oh what wait it shows here already okay
let me just go back
they go up on this this is a restricted
area there was like um
you know one of these do not enter poles
here
it's obviously a stage for some kind of
performance
and
um they went up here
disneyland paris apologized after an
employee interrupted a marriage proposal
at the amusement park
the video posted on reddit shows a man
dressed in white
where it was time stamped it just has a
video yeah
we don't necessarily need
all that why do they play it 20 times
okay here we go
here we go i don't know why they didn't
circle it with a big red circle and an
error so he proposed
dude was like no [ __ ] take the reed
took the ring
by the way i gotta respect a man in a
tight white shirt who's a little
overweight like that
that's his that's his proposal outfit
bro you gotta respect that man has no
shame and i love that
that's the smallest shirt the whitest
shirt he could find
tucked his ass all into that for the big
day
i'm just saying man you got to respect
that dude for that he has no shame
love that for him
i would nev and i'm a big fat guy too i
wear big ass baggy black shirts but this
man's like no tight and white
chat is saying that he got permission
too the initial oh [ __ ] yeah according
to the initial poster on reddit he did
ask for permission oh that's horrible
this guy the employee has the bunny ears
on and everything like damn
that that is so [ __ ] up if you got
permission
so i'm seeing in the new york times
article
that he asked a different employee
like went up and whispered to them like
can i go up there and do a proposal and
they were like yeah sure go ahead but
then
the wrong person to ask apparently
because this other employee uh did not
get the memo and but you got to respect
that this disney here let's listen to
what they say here because it's kind of
good
yes that's great but it's over here
she's going to be even better
he said she said we could he says yes
that's great but do it over here it's
going to be even better i [ __ ] up this
guy's employee of the year though that
guy loves disney
right that takes some damn puts but i
don't know
someone's engagement i think i'm i think
i think i'm
anti-employee he got booed too that's
awesome disney's supposed to be about
happiness and dreams and he just [ __ ]
up he had somebody else's permission
they said yeah go ahead but he didn't
know the one on there boy didn't know
that okay we still have to intercept the
ring like that dude that guy friend
they're like sealed team sick man this
guy's a well-trained special ops look at
this
he sniped that [ __ ] no pitch down nope
and he took the ring he's like you can't
stay up there now down [ __ ] taking the
ring is a bit much for sure so next
level you know when like i think promote
him somebody said dwight schrute energy
oh yeah big time like when you're in
elementary school and the teacher like
assistant is so excited to get you in
trouble that's what that feels like
i i don't know if people are just
memeing about this but i think disney
does have some type of proposal package
i think
oh he they didn't pay for it right
i think he's right that because i know a
lot of people do it and i think there is
like an official channel to do it
through so does this guy wear this
outfit you were usually
he did it all right the whole marriage
thing well hold on he's been all white i
mean what the heck bro that outfit is
next level [ __ ]
no i didn't say that stop it alex alex
jones he's an angel that's mean yeah he
looks angelic
that's not what i meant this is
europeans
in my mouth this is how they do it out
in disneyland paris
look at all the people watching too dude
okay but at the same time let's just say
this guy didn't get the memo and you
can't people you can't do whatever you
want at disney people probably testing
them them all the time going up on
stages doing [ __ ] fountains i don't
think the employees should get trouble
or anything like that that's not what
i'm saying but
you know
we don't have the whole picture here but
i'm seeing an empty stage there's no one
around they're not [ __ ] hurting
anything they might have been about to
do a show
i i guess maybe maybe you can't make it
i'm just saying disney is you need to
order at disney you have
thousands of people there
they have to keep it happy
gary klein energy someone said
i disagree
i'm just like go ahead i want chaos at
disney i don't know
my bloodshed
i want to just climb on stuff and do
whatever i want proletariat rise up at
disney yeah yeah
but the dude was already on one knee and
how fast was the guy running to come
intercept that ring like
yeah i mean dan said they were you know
it's already happening
just let him do it and then be like
excuse me sir you don't have to step up
could it be that some one of his
managers like get them off stage right
now that's why i'm saying i don't have
the whole picture and i don't think i
don't think that you know
i'm not saying [ __ ] that employee or
anything like that like he's just doing
his job but it it's a bit excessive do
we have do we know if this one has
special ops oh they definitely do he's
maybe special after funny with the rap
but the [ __ ]
they were down in the command center
he's ring sniper
yeah ring sniper 69. bye [ __ ] they took
their ring dude
yeah
exactly
i love you can hear the uh audience
applause slowly die down oh they start
booing him at the end watch yeah
yes that's right
here she's gonna be even better what a
[ __ ] dick
so let's do a pull i want to do a poll
on this one okay but so let's take all
into account let's just say should the
employee let's say
is he a good employee or a bad employee
is that a fair pull or like i'm
wondering i don't think that's a fair
framing because from the metric of good
employee yeah he was probably
doing the company policy there you know
what i mean but like was that so how do
we how do we gauge this in a fair way to
him
does he have a soul
was it like justified
was it justified
was it justified the guy hates couples
and marriage maybe that's it
yeah was it justified i mean
that's a little unfair framing
i feel like there's more framing than is
he a good employee because is he a good
employee i think by the letter of the
law of like dude
he did a good job for disney i mean yeah
that's what i'm saying i think
even though i was saying i was on the
side of of the uh couple i would still
say he was a good employee doing that
but i'm pretty sure disney swooped in
and gave him like lifelong tickets and
[ __ ]
yeah because it became like a pr
nightmare for him
we got new york times articles about
this now
disney apologizes after employee
thwart's marriage proposal i mean it's
an it's an honest-to-god great video
clip though
let's do paul
i don't think justified
okay let's do justified it's a little
unfair to him but let's do just employee
justified
stopping the proposal yeah let's do that
yes or no let's get a temp check on you
guys let's see
all right let's find out
are the bad pulls up bad pull bad pull
already
you know i'm gonna say
the thing is you feel like a bad person
saying yes
but i gotta say
you need order
[Music]
law and order baby i'm a law and order
guy should she suffer no yeah you're
definitely a long order guy 63 percent
though
but 34 yes law and order third of the
audience say yes
it's a great [ __ ] clip either way
obviously a brutal takedown by uh mouse
team six
oh give me the ring
there you go
well i'm sad it's over because i just
enjoyed that so much
you want to just sit in silence until
we have another 20 minutes to fill
thank you thanks for that
yeah i mean this the initial caption on
reddit poster said this piece of [ __ ]
destroy my best friend's moment
he asked for permission beforehand
that is kind of dude that is so epic
like the big moment you you're on the
knee you literally just need like
15 more seconds you put on your spandex
white shirt i'm saying you're wearing
all white
you got i know there's not a there's not
even a scuff on your beautiful white
outfit it's tight you're tucked in white
jeans too hard to pull off but your
rocks oh man
you know he ate some uh
i don't know what's a disney food
churros or turkey leg turkey leg you
know he had a
turkey what's that ice cream that
everyone's crazy about the pineapple
whip the doll where you know he had some
dual whip on that day my friend
he went to the buzz lightyear cafe
[Laughter]
yeah there you have it jimmy lee we have
we have a jimmy lee challenge yes so
i i walked in this morning to
everyone in the office
gathered around watching this um and
they it was just finishing is this the
new one this is the new one this was
recorded a day before he came on the
show a couple weeks ago
this was i think he used this sorry to
interrupt go ahead go ahead he he uh he
used
when we were originally supposed to go
out with him this was the day he shifted
[ __ ] around okay so this is the this is
got it yeah this is what you where you
were supposed to be with him
right right and thank god we weren't and
the reason it's in the dark
framed as a challenge
is they think that you won't be able to
make it like 30 seconds through this
without ethan like this is this is the
worst thing i've ever this is the worst
[ __ ]
ever
he's gotten worse so can i ask a
question like
do we ju because this was the day before
he came on our show and i feel like we
had a breakthrough on the show right so
can we judge him for this i mean
to be the full context of it though is
that this was his redemption
moment so he should have cleaned up his
act theoretically right right right i
guess uh having seen this
i don't know if there's helping this man
he also posted this after
like he posted this this was posted
yesterday yeah okay so
but exactly this was after the first or
second time he came on
recently he posted it yesterday he
posted it yesterday yeah no i mean that
he recorded it this is when he was in in
l.a
to shoot with us so what was that like a
month the second time yeah yeah the day
before his last appearance this could
have been us so you guys discussed him
changing his act before this oh yeah
that was the whole point of him coming
here yeah there were extensive phone
calls all the comments are really nice
ethan i'm i'm just i'm not right well mr
hollywood the jersey outlaw
i gotta say too
when dan walked in this morning he saw
us watching it and he had nothing he
wanted nothing to do with it
he just walked to his desk with a with a
sprout on
he's exonerating himself in the
situation have you guys seen his um
instagram has been pretty off the rails
his instagram
is the funniest thing he's ever done
it's so good shout out to mason
he showed that that and really
incredible photoshop of him with jimmy
kimmel like three times
one of him
is my favorite yeah that's that's a real
photo and him a new one too he is cam's
number now
how did you get your number cameron
because when um after the show he made a
critical number when we were sitting on
the couch
and he's been texting me just as much as
zack and i love it too like i mean
i you know i say oh great work jimmy or
whatever and then sometimes i'll send
him a social media poster too for him
does he does he chat you up or is that
just his act uh too much but
i don't respond a lot of the time
anyways to most people so cam cam turned
to me after he got his number and he
asked for it he's like i did this for
you [ __ ] yeah
well i'm taking the heat off
i haven't watched it yet
so let's not jump to uh
a harsh crit criticism here
this is of course by the way you guys
are talking about a man who parted with
tupac look at his face
jimmy you gotta stop look at his face
bro just zoom in on his face
he looks like a wax figure favorite part
holy [ __ ] jimmy is this real ass this
commenter yes
yeah it is
i mean he is old
this is actually the night tupac got
killed
yeah oh no
you made this one kim
oh did you make these cameron because
they're so good
yeah he asked if he was gonna get suit
for him
oh and he's got him holding up his
magazine yeah i did one more too wait
this is new i haven't seen this one yeah
i just did it the other day
he's been posting that other one
ten times i figured you need a new one
all right guys guys let's just watch it
everybody
let's watch with an open mind we love
jimmy lee he's a sweetheart he loved you
hold it i want to check audio audio
audio
how's the audio
i gotta say
even though that was such a funny moment
that is the worst meme that has ever
happened to this channel because people
constantly spam in our chat audio audio
audio
and every time i see it i'm like what's
wrong with the audio like we need with
our audio we need a jimmy lee emoji that
you can use with it yeah that's a great
idea please all right well without
further ado the jersey outlaw mr
hollywood himself
dangerously funny and holly you ball
player yeah when you're with the girls
you dribble and shoot but yeah
she told me around 10 o'clock she lets
the air out of them bay it ain't polite
the point you son of a [ __ ]
most boring people i met tonight
jimmy lee the jersey outlaw hollywood
california
we're ready
we're set let's go
so where are you guys all from they're
all different heights what the hell is
this i'm from missouri but i'm out here
playing basketball and going to school
well looking at you it's got to be
lonely in the prairies where are you
from
germany
put the rifle down there's two jews
around the corner where are you from
miami
that is just so brutal you know the
germans are very sensitive about that
it's not really an appropriate joke
here's a cookie where are you from i'm
from burbank let me be honest with you
let me show you how your awareness will
look a little better
oh [ __ ]
jimmy you are not
you are not
doing that
ethan it just gets worse from her
whoa he's just getting warmed up this is
not even the bad part
whoa jimmy
oh my
where are you from god vegas you're gay
because if not you're on a waiting list
you oh dude what the [ __ ]
got me ice cream you were so considerate
don't give him
are you [ __ ] serious
you actually bit her ice cream
oh my god yo
what
he's mr hollywood
to do that
[Music]
okay
i guess he's yours
no you know what mom
it was so considerate i asked her to
pick me up on ice cream and she got me a
nice ice cream thank you so much
jimmy you just ruined that woman's ice
cream
at this point she might think he is
famous because all the people around him
but later on when she finds out he's not
she might press charges
[Laughter]
i mean like if you do that joke which is
still really
a lot
he should like
pass her a tenner right at least maybe
he does it
i think he did honestly yeah you think
he did
yeah he gave money to some homeless dude
that chased us when we were out so i
think he slipped her a tenner or
something at least oh well then then
well it's still
okay he's can you ask him zach try to
get an answer on that well he just texts
me okay
watching now
jimmy jimmy did you pass that girl a
tenor or something how much did you did
you give her any money for the ice cream
bite or you consider she can still eat
it so why would you pay her i'll text
him that also yeah
even asked me if i wanted something
no i can we get jimmy to call in
well we have our other call in 10
minutes but maybe after [ __ ] yeah maybe
after don't share
you don't share we love jimmy lee you
are beautiful
thank you
you're available for a drink
or
are they available for a drink oh
my god that's so gnarly bro that's just
her that's just sexual harassment that's
not even a joke is it
no just because you have a camera
straight up you've literally just filmed
yourself committing a crime jimmy
if they are i'm buying take care of you
listen to me it ain't polite the point
you son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
i love how he's like decrepit
like he just kind of punched over it's
the jimmy walk it's like the crypt walk
you know
yeah
because he
he's been doing this a while
getting a little exhausted this is crazy
bro this is not oh by the way this is
season six episodes nine i didn't
realize yeah
yeah
season five came out a week ago so i'd
say jump the shark at this point jimmy
i'm sorry
hey
buddy right here how you doing this is
my lover and uh last night we were
making passionate love he got wild with
me taught me to defend any then he left
you know but why'd you do that i mean
you're supposed to be very passionate
we all go on vacations the cool thing
about that is everybody comes we all
have a good time we've heard that
tonight
you're going to be with with geo and i'm
going to be with uh david david david
and i we have a really nice time
last night david was cochise he put warp
paint on his ass and he got on the bed
and said go geronimo lady what wow
dude
it's just it's just next level
all right this next part how old do you
think these girls are before we get into
this these girls look like maybe 16 14
15. wait no let's oh even less
all right i got a sorry but i gotta see
what he does what's he's gonna do you
think these girls are 13 14 no no no
maybe 14 15. okay 15. let's see i would
say like 15 to 17. okay okay agreed
underage i'd say
definitely here we go
they look like a cab hit you on an angle
when we go on hunting he always says
that what does that mean to get we i
think i guess we asked him our head at
an angle it didn't end up being
he couldn't explain it real real quick i
just asked him about the ice cream he
said no it was a gag
i told you he didn't pay her
he said it was a guy
though he said no it was a gag she
filmed it
no he didn't pay her i know i know oh
she's he's saying because she filmed it
he didn't
because she got caught so that justifies
it yeah she was filming it for evidence
dude
that's awesome i knew he did because
when he's doing his shtick he just he
hits and he what moves
there's no lingering there's no reaching
into the wall it's like boom gone
he said you guys are killing me be nice
jimmy what do you want me to do this is
this is
lunacy jimmy what about your poor
victims
this is lunacy i know what about the
victims man
this is so hard to do to watch jimmy
you can't pull you posted this yesterday
you can't do this stuff this is the
whole point of our intervention was
we literally had an intervention and you
posted this yesterday what am i supposed
to say
you know that northern girls go to
heaven yeah southern girls go where go
everywhere
because northern girls say you can but
southern girls say y'all can i only go
out with southern girls they don't yell
they don't yell and they don't smell
i have no clue what just happened
neither do they good for you girls you
come now really are you coming
well if you're coming i'm showing up
listen i'm double trouble is that right
deal with threesome now use both hands
you know what i mean oh okay
listen i scream when i say these women
are like am i being sexually harassed
right now so in front of a camera jimmy
just said to the ice cream again she
said
i said you didn't pay her question mark
he said yes she thought i'm period big
star that's why yep that's what i
thought
perfect okay perfect
the joke of course is that you're not
and you just ruined her ice cream
if you're a big star it'd be fine
humorous who said that she thought he
was a big star he it
no but like did she say to him wow
you're a big star
nobody said that i think just because
the recording because she was recording
him she assumed yeah
right and then the audaciousness of
biting her ice cream frankly i could
watch this whole video i find it
endlessly fast okay we we have a call
soon uh and we have we should really do
our ads before that so let's do our ads
let's talk to wally and then jimmy if
you're around let's get you on a call
and watch this but jimmy i can't i can't
keep having these interventions with you
like
we got to see the new ones working he
said classic jimmy lee
what room someone's great classic
jimmy you've got to stop sexually
harassing people on camera you're going
to go to jail
or get sued and we wish we all we want
the best for the outlaw actually we
don't want you to be a real outlaw we
want you just play the character
let me watch one more [ __ ] one more bit
especially if she walks in on us you
know what i'm talking about oh yeah oh
no we don't want that what we do how you
doing i'm great good to see you back to
women's clothes you look but it's been a
while
uh well everybody hates me they want to
take pictures they take the pictures
they throw them in the garbage nobody
really cares for this kind of comedy i
just got from some lady one finger up
and things aren't going real well in
fact the tv people they're upset and i'm
going to be canceling next week they
were actually hoping it was this week
nice to meet you all right okay
put the guns down put your guns down
get the hookers out put the guns down
exactly
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hold on let me
let me capture that moment again
[Music]
walks over bullets put the guns down
what do you say he said what books over
bullets oh cause he has a gun on his on
his hoodie
oh my god oh okay
okay
all right is that how does that make it
a little yeah i mean it's not uh that's
context
that one like a bullet yeah
put the guns down
get the hookers out put the gun down
exactly
listen hookers in hollywood have it made
they can drop it drape and droop it
listen you know what good thing about a
hooker they got it they sell it they
still got it absolutely you're a hot
mama
whoa
it's a stunning man if i may say so oh
my god whoa
ooh
you look like a hasid
man get a shot of a bee he's got the
curling i i've just been twirling this
the whole video i'm sorry i fidget
whenever i'm stressed he turns jewish
[Laughter]
dude jimmy you gotta know that that
that's just horrible man he he just
called me he's calling
nice to meet you he's a stunning man if
i may say so oh a stunning man
no twice yeah
yeah exactly right do i have mine
there it is
jimmy we we gave you a whole redemption
arc and you post this [ __ ]
[Music]
all right we'll let we can deal with
jimmy
another time another time yeah but holy
smokerinos
people are saying they'd rather watch
ads well your wish is my command
[Laughter]
it's a good strategy to do this before
that all right well everyone stick
around i'm gonna thank our sponsors and
then we're gonna get on a call with
wally and hopefully he's a little more
palatable than jimmy
his counterpart jimmy
well anyway thank you to expressvpn
watching netflix without using
expressvpn is like going to a casino and
only being able to play the slot machine
why limit yourself like that the big
money somewhere else
listen
expressvpn is going to help you watch
netflix and other streaming apps because
they have different libraries for every
country netflix has thousands of shows
but without a vpn you only get access to
a fraction of them based on your
location when you pop that baby on you
can
make the website think you're from any
country you want and therefore you can
say hey i live in japan and then netflix
is like cool here's the japanese content
which has like a bunch more
cool stuff and ips that they've got
but you know i love uh expressvpn
um japan is my favorite they've got all
this crazy anime they've got all the
miyazaki
movies
so that's the one i like but canada uk
they've all got really interesting extra
content
uh you know why should you choose the
expressvpn over other vpns they're
blazing fast streaming hd with zero
buffering
uh compatible with all your devices
phone laptop media console smart tvs and
more
and
they work in over 94 different countries
gain access to thousands of new shows so
be smart stop paying full price for
streaming services and only getting
access to a fraction of their content
get your money's worth at expressvpn.com
h3
don't forget to use our link at
expressvpn.com
h3 and get an extra three months
of expressvpn for free so thank you to
expressvpn
and thank you to harry's
harry
listen
listen
you need to shave right father's day is
coming up
it's time to show some gratitude to your
daddy
and actually i think this is a good gift
for the dads because
you know you don't have to choose
between a great shave and a fair price
and with father's day right around the
corner there's never been a better time
to try or share the harry's experience
you can get a starter kit for just three
bucks
that's a cheap father's day present
let's be real let's go
but it looks like it's worth more so
thank you or get a free engraving on any
premium shave set for dad when you go to
harrys.com h3 harry's gift set are the
perfect gift for any guy in your life
and their winston razor handle is
engraved so you can make father's day
even more memorable
harry's delivers a close comfortable
shave at a fair price still as low as
two dollars per blade
their blades are designed to stay sharp
and in a recent study
guys who shave four times a week said
their eighth shave with harry's was just
as smooth as their first
here's prioritizes simple quality
craftsmanship that gives you exactly
what you need there's no uh pricey
gimmicks or unnecessary bells and
whistles which is a great razor
at a great price
and there's no risk if you don't like it
boom get your money back
so harry's is giving their best offer
right now to our listeners new harry's
customers can get a starter set for just
three bucks
or for a limited time through father's
day get free engraving on any premium
shave set at harrys.com h3
never been a better time to try harry so
go to harrys.com h3 to start your own
harry's journey
or save a few bucks on a gift for a
special dad in your life there you have
it harry's love that
and
stamps.com
we love stamps.com you know if you're
running a small business
every second count you can't afford to
waste a single moment and also every
dollar counts let's be real
you're going to be saving a lot of time
and money using stamps.com if you're
mailing anything you understand you
don't even have to think about it dude
stamps.com makes mailing and shipping
quick easy and cost effective
for more than 20 years stamps.com has
been indispensable for over 1 million
businesses stamps.com gives you access
to the post office ups shipping services
right from your computer and here's the
best part you get discounts you can't
find anywhere else 30 percent off usps
and 86 percent off ups
streamline your shipping process with
sams.com easy to use software all you
need is your regular computer and a
printer
no special supplies or equipment you're
up and running in minutes printing
official postage for any letter any
package anywhere you want to send
stamps.com seamlessly works with shopify
amazon etsy
ebay and more
so if you're running an office doing
invoices or on etsy sitting products or
even a big ass warehouse
shipping out orders stamps.com is your
best friend
uh your girlfriend uses stamps.com right
dan
she does she does and she uses it for
all of those things that you just listed
well not the big ass warehouse we don't
have a big-ass warehouse we have a
closet in our apartment but she
really makes it easy because it makes it
so easy they give you a scale so you
weigh it you get the perfect weight
then you put i guess it's connected to
the computer it weighs it it prints out
the postage and then the best part is
you just put it on your door or in your
mailbox if it fits and it automatically
goes out i mean it couldn't be more
convenient you don't even have to think
about it exactly thank you stephen
so stop wasting time and start saving
money when you go to stamps.com to mail
and ship sign up with the promo code h3
for a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale there's no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the page and enter the code
h3 thank you to stamps.com we love them
all right thank you guys thank you to
all of our sponsors
[Music]
so are we having wally ready
he is ready he's in the waiting strap
into your seats boys and girls
so um so again this will be wally and
tony who's going to be uh helping speak
wali's so let me let him in right now
all right this is a big moment guys
everyone clench your butt cheeks thank
you to over
this is a big big moment
my whole life has led
waiting for this
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
can you turn it yeah uh for some reason
the uh video is um
no no it's literally flipped to the side
like you guys are uh
oh that's weird yeah i don't know why it
there we go there we go let me just
oh yeah
all right we got it it was supposed to
be like that but it's all good no
worries
now let me just first of all say welcome
wally
you are an internet celebrity it's such
an honor to have you here
uh thank you
thank you god bless you god bless you
now who is tony how did you guys meet
uh this is my friend
was
[Music]
all right so
uh basically
my friend was telling me about wally
right
and
he was telling me about him and how he
would call him every day and all this
stuff my friend lives in like he lives
in austin right and uh he gave me his
address and i was just curious he gave
me wally's address i don't know how he
got it right
um
and basically
i checked on google how far away while
he lived
he gave me wally's phone number and
everything like he knows everything
about wally
right it's not weird and yeah i know
it was weird but uh
basically um
i was like you know what maybe maybe
i'll bring him something because you
know he he lives like 30 minutes away
from me i drive 30 minutes every week to
see wally 30 minutes oh that's beautiful
and um
so basically the first time we met
i picked up some
fries from mcdonald's fries got it yeah
he likes mcdonald's fries with no salts
nothing like salt good good
fries
it's healthier right
yeah
yeah um and then i called wally and i
was like hello is this is this the real
muhammad
and he was like yeah yeah it's real
muhammad and
i came over to the address i got a
little bit lost i got actually a little
bit scared um i
i was in a
particularly
nice car right what kind of car you
drive dude flex on us
[Applause]
um because my car is getting fixed but
we're not talking about that um
and basically i came around here i see
all these like mexican trollos and stuff
where wally lives like playing like
basketball or something like hanging out
so you know i come from like a like a
more
um
i guess like
area with more careful there tony
yeah yeah i'm trying not to get like you
know i don't want the nra guys or
anything to uh
oh we got company bring him on in let's
do a party
oh no no he's getting his ac fixed don't
don't mind that um
so can i ask tony or wally can i ask you
a question
how do you feel about tony's friend
knowing your address and phone number
i put my address in the facebook and
youtube and the
keystock
oh you say anyone can visit you just not
muslims
yes because i know
that michael
[Music]
business but i basically come into my
business
sign up with me and i go to the lawyer
they take everything for me
tony
what is he saying tony okay so
basically he doesn't like muslims and
because
when he was in the army
his son had to tell the story to me
because he couldn't even interesting
interesting
and
um son told me that
when he was in the army he got captured
by saddam hussein's army oh and he was
in a pow camp for nine years oh my
goodness well got like tortured by all
these like arabs and muslims and stuff
so but but wally are you is is wally
you're you are uh of arab uh descent
right
but that
is that not considered
no it's not uh wally it's taking calls
anything interesting
so you're kurdish but so but do you
think it's fair to say you don't like
any arab any muslim we don't we don't we
don't fraternize with them at all
no not all of them saying some other
good but yeah
would kill me bad work
and i go very much because they put some
stuff nasty for me
my family and uh
i see and people
i go mad and i tell everyone
i'll show you something you know
some other very nice but not all of them
you know okay
okay oh sorry go ahead yeah i caught
that one i got that one i'm i'm picking
up on his dialect uh wally is there
anyone else you won't hang out with or
is it just the the muslims
he's saying like is there anybody else
you would hang out like you wouldn't
hang out with or is it just muslim
people you don't like them
i know people no one hundred percent but
when athletes
[Music]
to me in the phone when i see i go go
mad and i put the quran put into my
shoes you know
i say all muslim not good okay
i just wanted to a b here of course uh
is a really sweet guy of ours
he's uh
i know
yeah he's he's actually muslim
he's he's lebanese he's a good guy
though what did he say i talked to him
yeah he said he knows who you are oh
but he's one of the good ones
yeah
alina can you do you guys both are
speaking uh what was the arabic yeah
yeah uh lena do you wanna you wanna talk
you wanna translate for us because you
speak you speak arabic right yeah i do
so let's maybe get lena here to sit with
ab lena has a camera oh yeah lena has
her own camera
a little bit turkey you know okay
can you ask him who he supports joe
biden or donald trump
1970 now i never give no one both and
negligence in the white house i give him
one what is why do you like mitt romney
so much because nick romney is they say
i make a tax cut
i do a lot of stuff
because
people working
you know working hard you pay tax
some people not working
like eight calls a day
go ahead and you can put them on speaker
if you or maybe not maybe not don't put
it on speaker actually
maybe yeah go ahead and take the call
that's fine can you call it
a little bit maybe
because now it's the people on the line
you know yeah yeah yeah
so amy
he has a friend named a.b okay
interesting yeah
i think it's in iraq on near the border
of iran okay it's like northern northern
iraq is that right northern iraq yeah
right
right okay interesting and how long did
you live there what was your life like
there
was so many years in the iran couple
come back to iraq and
foreign
you you work for the cia is that what
you said
uh inc i enc
oh what
was the
uh that sounds familiar uh international
uh the ilc was safe
okay uh the the oil company
no this is the army all me oh the army
the army yes by all but but the money
for usa for the atmosphere
so you serve
so you grew up there
and you served in the army you were
fighting saddam hussein's army
yes i see i see
and
my id from inc was my
i see i see
and did you celebrate when saddam
hussein was was uh
hung by the united states
what bad guy you know they know like
it's like you know luck you're saying
and
they killed a bunch of kudos in his life
and they put in the ground
and they put 182 000 by the god they
yeah he was very brutal to your people
did so when growing up did a lot of
people and family die to in war and
stuff
they put for the life the child the lady
the man the ground
by machine gun they shoot some people
and
now
usa
and so you fought in the war
and then at what point did you move to
the united states
[Music]
to iran and usa san soo jack airport
from zappo
we come into usa uh bazaani people they
come in the airplane they come in for
the guam
and
usa we comment in the
[Music]
[Music]
will come back to ankara
and capable
of doing the paperwork what happened to
our
deals
and they say this family
make growth free country
[Music]
okay and then when you moved to united
states what did you do for work
i came here
1997 to
1998.
first time i work in the fourth season
and i now have rights in
my hand is
the part you know they open their
computer they hit my hand in
my life and
i can go to work
and say in the low income after this one
i say about
the
couple
you know
one guy was
this company special receiver for me
not everything
what could you understand
i would say well he came here in 1997
and he was selling something for 450
yeah
easter bunny
you understand everything i'm saying
quite well is it frustrating that people
have a hard time understanding what you
say
apparently he doesn't
wally why does joe biden need to wake up
uh because
i know they can go pass away they have
some balloon they eat
but they have some gold in the blood not
go
that's why i would say you're going to
go to hospital check out your body
go one year or six months or three years
you will pass away right
because then you say
you said joe biden very soon you go to
hell can you want to unpack that one
oh that was a joke that was a joke very
soon you go to hell
are you are you uh
yeah yeah
you seem to have a good sense of humor
[Music]
every morning they took me
like what i'm born they love because
they're three kids and the father
whatever me
another brother another one they don't
tag
that's beautiful
so just to recap we love the jews we
love the christians we hate the muslims
yes yes
my family
they
they love muslims because they believe
with god but just me not believe
maybe you guys try maybe you guys try
speaking in arabic that would be
interesting
lena can you ask him
if he sees a muslim dude on the street
is he throwing hands or is he just like
how bad is is it
it's a petrol farm
uh
yeah what do you say elena
he answered in english i think yeah but
he's a pacifist he doesn't believe in
violence
yeah she basically asks if it's on site
if he sees a muslim he said no no no he
doesn't believe in that even if somebody
hit you with this side even the other
side
he's turning turning the other chain
yeah yeah no we got you we got it jesus
said what's your favorite um
what do you do to pass the time wally
what what what's your hobbies what's
your interests
now i have a problem i can't drive the
car not far away because uh when i go to
surveillance register by my
car they put in the lighting over my car
oh where you're back you're back i can
see you
yeah he can't drive
no not far away because
my office said every time
they cannot take up me and his officer
[Music]
can you
can you ask him lena did he say his
officer
is he on probation or something
he's on five years probation what did he
do
what happened
out with my apartment
and then i'm coming up arkansas
lives they open i pass pioneer and
police follow me and i was rather
emergency in the turkey government when
you have emergency one question
one in the back and i
though you know
confused confused and they follow me and
the light i stop and open the light
bro
i got my mama apartment
you had drinking is that what happened
you were no no no no oh so so what
made
uh basically he was driving really fast
and
he got pulled over because of
that
his mom was having an emergency
but why did he get why did he get
probation
because please follow me
oh you ran you got it you got into a
police chase oh [ __ ] you got it
how many police were chasing you
yeah maybe
25 cars
25
quality
was it on the television yeah that's
crazy
something
you know maybe for somebody else's
government
something like government people work
here but the car they have was inside
system
and so how long did you lead them on a
police chase
all the way to your mom's house or did
you pull over before that
from
[Music]
oh my god how long does how long of a
driver
oh five miles oh okay not too bad and
the police for me another stop because i
have one emergency
they have to say that which i can take
reduction i say call the homeless they
say no we'll check it and i can all lie
no stop and the pioneer please stop me i
say i haven't really seen my
ex-wife this uh
the problem is the doctor tell me take
it to oslo
and the police in the back side they
helped me and they're not giving any
tickets another another time but for
them
oh yeah sure of course in gta it happens
i don't know about in real life
okay
oh [ __ ] wally we got your mug wait can
we i don't know if we could show this yo
okay you live in texas evading arrest
damn wally you're a wanted criminal
in 2001 was there
i helped the fbi in police
and the police saw me
so you're you're in text oh what were
you showing there
oh you work security
a bouncer did you have a gun or no
[Music]
so they have some problems
and police will suddenly do my job
and
leave it with you they call another card
and they put income in my hand
and technically the year
the kids go criminal after four years
next time
come and take your stroll back i say
keep the store just give the uniform in
my pocket
and everybody in the base all in one i
secretly go two gentlemen
one of them in the electorate one of
them in the discount
i
control the area what they the area five
police not kosovo by that myself they i
control when the
they put me in the jail no more people
bunch of people they call me they say
repair you just come back for the
excuse me i'd say no more
so what is the truth behind 911 do you
think wally
nine eleven a hundred percent while the
inside goes oh really
hundred percent of you because the one
pentagon hit by a rocket clothes and
that stuff and the rocket was
red quad class you see
my family they see no more no one talked
with me red cross and that in the in the
tub and the tub and the rockets so do
you think george bush did 9 11 was that
what happened
uh gk was inside the pentagon okay
they straw the people the white king
and the pentagon hit by rocky cross
inside the pentagon for the new york
i see all the companies because when fbi
and police carry my home i open all
files i watch what happened in the 911
the right copy not the copy you're
saying when you worked at the fbi
because you worked with the fbi at some
point right
when fbi came to my home they said we
wanted your help
and i opened the file was opened by the
911
[Music]
okay
that's interesting so 911 was an inside
job why is trump a bad boy can you
expand on that
when happened
they take bullets
yes i know that's true because the
turkish people not that kurdish
in iran they killed people
okay we don't like turkey then
because
pekka
free country you know
so what's your criticism you say trump
bad boy trump bad boy play the sound
bite
yeah this is the biggest question
homeless people with a low income you
buy a hub usa for 200 million dollars
and other things you cousin do not do
that not your mom why do you want to
defend
palestine yeah for aid yeah and he
didn't do anything he'd really do that
trump that's surprising yeah that is
fine so we don't like we don't like
helping the palestinian people in
general or just you thought that money
should have been spent
i'm not having any problem with that
they have
seen or not helped but
first time usa you have a bunch of
low-income
iraq will have a bunch of homeless in
the inside history
there you go
the homeless absolutely
[Music]
to iran to surya you know
there you have it
and ed
them what they do
we actually have a picture of the police
chase you guys went on
uh
five stars well anyway
um okay interesting and then basically
um
when i ask you another question here
you have such a good
concern i see something with the eye of
my eye if she has my name will tell us
yeah
the
gta 5 photo he didn't see the gta 5.
was it something like this wally
oh boy bad boy what you gonna do
it's very appropriate
it's like that one was that so is that
about like what will happen
not this girl well i'm on the ground
so
how do you know that joe biden has two
years to live is that well a lot less
now oh yeah now he doesn't have much
time to live at all are you worried
about his health and you want him to
live yeah right
uh i now not talk nothing because what i
know something happened outside
uh
i see sometimes when i see
sometimes like people tell me
wake up somebody need help
and i go help him one time i take two
backs what i was probably department
follow me
out for my apartment and when i take the
wall they say how we know we know
we need
water
and
foreign and i came back
to my apartment again
and what another time was the lady
they have a blood
and i come back from his back they say
what do you not need i say you want to
help me you're like you got involved in
the diet and i called them my friend
they couldn't open the tires
[Music]
and when i have money was i helped
california chose 15
uh cherry dollar tree
and
police go tag
50
75
one time they say we send
for the license plate 300.5 300
what i have money now on
disable
low income
yeah i want to play some sound bites for
you're very popular on this show wally
zach why don't you run through him and
let's just get his reaction here joe
bison wake up so that one's that one's
iconic that's you saying joe biden wake
up
right yes but uh people you know go like
my tick tock you know yeah you're a
celebrity
and then go play another one zack very
soon you go to hell yeah very soon you
go to hell yeah this is for you know
one time with the usa good one time
and then go ahead zach
what were you saying there maybe
something of the island
yeah anymore
what i have what was my call no ac no i
see
they buy this phone for full dollar and
amazon
by one week they sent to my addre
y'all want to see wally's lamborghini
aventador
sure love it
let me see that's like right
okay can you flip the camera around on
this thing i don't know how to oh here
we go all right
all right so
there's the wally mobile oh great
beautiful van
he got that car from his brother for
400.
my man that's a good deal right there
yeah so they probably sell more than
that for scrap
they pay like 500 for scraps
right here
yeah let's look around his house do you
mind if we look around your house wally
you don't care wally let's go yeah show
us around let me let's see how well it
looks let me let me give y'all a tour
real quick yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right so this is where you come in
right
um
and then this is the infamous the chair
right can you do me a favor buddy tony
do me a favor
smell the seed bro
i don't know
um wally are you okay with that
you want me to smell your [ __ ]
go ahead dude you're killing me ethan
give it a big old whiff you're there for
a reason tony you're you're our eyes and
ears
all right here we go guys here we go all
right
god
it's not
not that bad
it's not that bad but you gotta like
you've been eating some greasy foods or
something like that i i don't know i
don't know man i eat garlic on your
cheetah that's my man
yeah my man yeah we were we were getting
we were getting drunk on some seven up
we all called
and and some
lemonade
does he do that a lot tony just bust
into character like that
yeah dude like every time i come here
like off camera he's the same he's the
same
um
let's continue the tour
um so this is where he hangs up his
little uniform and uh it's the wally the
wali kitchen yeah
great um look at the let's see what's in
the cabinets
oh just a bunch of like
trash bags does he have food or anything
in there or like cereal i mean he has
these beans he buys like a okay he buys
like a whole
thing of beans right show up the beans
let me see that's a lot of beans what
kind of beans
and he lives off these for like half a
year dude lava beans
oh hell yeah he just eats them straight
out of the can huh
oh yeah yeah how does he eat that does
he use a utensil or does he use his hand
i don't know he puts it in this pita
bread or something where is
i guess it's is that garlic garlic all
right there's garlic in here a lot of
garlic i saw in one one of his videos
that he used to keep lemon juice under
the sink because now is that still no no
i uh that was when we went to we went to
sam's club and we bought like a crapload
of just lemon juice
he he drinks this stuff like yeah by
itself you know what can you can you
tell him that we tried his concoction of
lemon juice garlic in uh
does he drink water or just lemon juice
do you drink water wall-e
tell them i drink water
and
lemon okay they helped with the bottles
for the block be sure to come down and
somebody have a diabetes just drink hot
water and hot coffee no medicine any
anything
not you get hot water and
hot coffee no sugar and check out the
blood the sugar come down no need any
ncaa
can i ask a question i don't mean to be
rude i just
i have to ask
obviously wally you're you're a little
bit overweight
and i just wonder how do you sustain
that that physique with just beans
because i know how much money food is um
yes i buy the food because
the 215 dollars i put some today done
and i have money i buy tomato i buy a
bunch of food because
sometimes i go to mission answering for
the food because
people some people have a business
driveshaft inspection the whole weekend
the trials governments i'm talking about
disabled people you go edgy you work
just i have cheering you work in the usa
and i come into town retirement and
caring for work
and my is 853 dollars wanted to go to
child support it saved 650
[Music]
sometimes michelangelo
75 my brother was problem
so so you get other kinds of food banks
other food from food banks and charities
and stuff like that
yeah yeah pretty much but
my
brother
what helped me
pay six thousand dollars for my rent and
one year when my mother passed away i
was i lived with my mom when my mother
passed away no place my brother is with
his skilled car
they went for minutes of pokemon and
sometimes hundreds or sometimes without
the help of my rent but before problems
they pay 500 without with a much sick
i'm okay
but
it's okay now
uh
[Music]
just
come down the dog walk by me and they
broke their hand and down with
did y'all understand that no
but no i get the sediment
it did uh but basically he you just you
eat a lot of beans and pita and stuff
like that that's like the meal of
the favorite meal there i mean well okay
sometimes when i come here i i take
wally to go try new foods and like try a
lot of stuff and i pay for it
the reason he really doesn't eat
anything else because he can't afford it
um
and you know
yeah and he has no teeth right so i have
to get him some soft foods
nice um
if he if he had all the money in the
world what kind of what kind of food
would he want to eat
kebab kebab all day
just not pork not cool no
but you like kebab you like homeless
you like kebab right yeah any kind of
food american food any kind of food i
would have jumbo jack with a vegetable
because i'm not any problem just i have
problem with the pork i'm not eating
pork
no pork not everything else
alcohol
do you do the diet seven up or regular
seven up just a regular one yeah yeah
yeah
the good stuff no messing around with
that diet crab crap
the one time that wally
took me to eat somewhere and we made a
video about that i remember wally we
went to
he he takes me his favorite restaurant
is this kurdistan kebab place and it's
like super i guess like he pays like
12 dollars and they let him grab as much
as he wants so he's like
wow all you can eat for 12 bucks that's
that's 16 please
buy three or three hour units
okay wow
three hours anything anything
and you just stock up like a bear
hibernating bear
we we have a video of it somewhere
somebody has it i don't i
i'll have to find it i think i sent it
to somebody on snapchat or something and
they saved it hey what's that what's
that machine something under the table
on hit on wally's right side
he has asthma oh how does that machine
work
this is one how does how does it work
well uh this one here
you
should not walk
and this one here
you going
and they have uh the internet's
this this right here
yeah
what is that
let me uh i can lock it in place and
then rotate it see i hear you
hey uh zach can you message jimmy lee
and see if he would go pro bono teeth
work for wall-e yeah sure
oh well i would that would be the
ultimate redemption arc for jimmy i mean
that would be fun that would be
something else man
we know a dentist wally that might be
able to do help you out with your teeth
if you're if you want that
do you want teeth wally
i i wish but i have a tea i eat apple
[Music]
you know i have problem with that
so what if we but just tell you know
explain that we know a dentist that
might be able to help him out pro bono
yeah yeah um
so wally basically
they know a dentist that could help you
get teeth if you want help but they want
to surgery i try one time go to mission
lines and
they say eight thousand dollars they
wanna leave make a surgery
dentures just dentures
oh he can't use dentures oh really why
not
why can't you use dentures i
like the butt of the gun when he was
being yeah yeah
w he's louise perhaps his jaw to play
sound light
and the iraqi regime you know
the power
you know we could probably get a custom
denture though you know what i mean with
a good dentist
wally right now
has been saving up money to
we're well i'm we're trying to save up
for him and trying to raise money for
him right now uh on that we made a
gofundme and it raced like it's at like
250 right now yeah we're gonna watch the
yeah go ahead
uh he wants to buy a bus so that he
could fit his wheelchair
um because he can't go long distances
like on foot i guess like he gets really
sweaty and
breathes really hard
and it's just like one time we walked to
my car from here and like it looked like
he just had a full like workout
right so he needs like a handicapped van
that has one of those ramps that you can
drive the mobility yeah
yeah with with the van what what kind of
what would he be doing if he uh if he
had that van what would he want to be
doing
yeah they have the
jack come down and
the
bigger and
by one
sometimes you know done in my elevation
i normally stay in the apartment i wanna
so he kind of basically wants like an rv
with a wheelchair eject like an
automatic electric like you know
wheelchair ejecting thing
ramp whatever so so he wants to
he wants to travel uh like go on
vacation like travel uh
yeah and wally has uh
we're talking about bringing wally to my
house
to make a video
and
yeah
so okay first of all
jimmy lee he's uh he's a world renowned
dentist he says he's willing to to do
the work for free
for wally to do whatever he needs
like
teeth stuff for free
he's a great dentist one of the best in
the country is is he in texas though or
like how how well he's in he's in new
jersey but we can figure something out
without fun yeah
but then the other thing that i want to
do is i want that gofundme so that we i
want to drop i want to drop some money
in there
for wally and i'm sure some people in
the chat would want to help out too uh
let me let me see real quick
oh and he wants to get liposuction he
wants to get liposuction oh oh he wants
to get the oil out
yeah
basically liposuction
um
uh let me go ahead and get that gofundme
link yeah i we need i mean we need a
jimmy axe wall-e
crossover anyway
to get jimmy and wally i mean
well wally isn't very mobile i think
jimmy would have to he would have to
come to new jersey because that's where
his office is well that's true but i
don't know
we'd have to
figure out the logistics a little bit
more
because i have almost
uh in the king my gun
one
okay i've got the gofundme i am putting
it in our chat
right now
and pinning it
okay
beautiful picture
so i took that picture it was a great
picture
all right so here's what i'm gonna do
straight off the bat i'm just gonna send
this to my
accountant i'm gonna i'm gonna have her
donate a thousand dollars from us
get that going okay
thank you thank you god bless you god
bless you you've brought me you know
what that draws and you know what while
i use that money for whatever you need
you know i mean
don't you don't feel don't feel
obligated to do anything that's your
money you do with whatever you want with
it you know what i mean if you suddenly
tell
yeah yeah yeah exactly just just be
comfortable can you drop that in the
chat so i can send it to my account it's
not in the discord oh got it curtis and
like prostitutes or something
prostitutes
no i i have clothes for that put it in
my country that should uh
everything but in my country yeah i have
my country because i'm black but the
people that i do the turkey government
syria iran
they know that and tells bunch about
the works of people we have a bunch of
people die you know
tag in the iraqi regime
[Music]
people
and that's why we don't want to be no
more iran no more iraq no more
if there's muslims watching is it okay
with you if they donate or do not want
their money
i know you need money for muslims
i was just donating
so so we don't we're not accepting
donations from muslims
yes just jews and christians okay just
what about atheists can they donate
like people that don't believe in
anything
yeah
it's not believing anything is okay but
not
just not
so guys if you're watching
what
[Music]
what about lebanese
lebanese
[Music]
he's muslim from lebanon he was just
going to donate 100 so should he put his
card away
you can't say people are hungry
but he wants you to instead donate that
hundred dollars to people that are
hungry so he's not saying don't donate
it's just you personally won't take your
god
[Music]
okay so everybody in the audience
there's we put out the gofundme
if there's any muslims i'm very sorry
uh but we don't have no donation
i know
no one but there's no need money from
muslim because they kill kurdistan
people because some people iran they
kill
wally can i challenge you a little bit
okay go ahead i mean a b was born in leb
his family's from lebanon i mean i i
don't think they had anything to do with
that very tragic uh
uh
killing of your of of your countrymen
but good luck too they know about
kurdish people nobody's not kurdish
people you think all muslims hate the
kurds
mike's girlfriend
okay so a b says that he used to date
a kurdish girl what do you think about
that
okay can i
ask him
one question oh [ __ ]
what do you mean
by english
lina lina did you catch that lina
[Music]
b
send is army uh christian people they go
you go to hell you go to fire you are
not muslim you're christian
but probably
one thousand four hundred a year ago
probably muhammad
muslims believe christians and jews are
going to hell
is that the problem there
no how many problems because the bible
quran very close you have ishmael in the
quran you have moses in the quran
you have abraham in the quran
all the prophets
that islam believes all the prophets
were actually muslim like jesus and
everyone oh and you you know but the
prophet said if we are not brothers in
faith and religion then we are brothers
and facing in uh humanity
right the quran the quran the bible
but american american people they
the christian people they hear the bible
and then you go in the egypt bible our
bible we see with the quran
all sin adam
and and
that's true he's saying the other
religious books have all changed
throughout the years the quran is the
one that stays the same yeah that's a
principle of the quran it's supposed to
not be altered in any way
that's interesting
i think he checkmated you there maybe
from a certain point of view because it
could be altered then it could be
altered by man why it's not known about
christian people
people they go cluster so many army i
was i was working
on them
uh first week while they pay 150 second
week they pay
10 years 10 days i work for the hundred
percent and 15 days i work for 100 it
was my child small
and
they wanted milk
and
the car to leave you know what i drive
towards
no insurance one time my brother begged
the other car they took 14 tickets
[Laughter]
listen wally
my i just put a thousand dollars in your
gofundme and also all the people
watching all the generous incredible
family members you guys are so
incredible even without the help of our
muslim fans we were able to raise
already three thousand dollars
three thousand dollars on your gofundme
right now
thank you god bless you thank you god
bless you god bless you my friend
god bless you uh you know
any for the pc state the black white
spanish
canada surrounding any country they help
christian and jewish i love them
we love them
because i love how i love kurdistan i
love business
okay let me ask you a question let me
ask you this what do you think about
indonesian people because they're muslim
but they're not arab
way
he said that so indonesian people you
know indonesia the the countries they
eat
people with this country
people people what
oh no no no that's i think you're
thinking of a different place
i would just say i'm the product of
christian and muslim love my mom was
christian when she met my dad so abe is
half christian half muslim do we buy
that
the question is the question is
probably
jesus
the
[Music]
is
let's move on i feel like we're not
i feel like we're not getting anywhere
but you know
but it is what it is and that's okay
let's continue the house store i was
fascinated by that all all right so we
saw the kitchen yeah so over there is
the kitchen right and then this the the
wally area can i get a close-up of the
table beside him what's on the table
there
oh just uh
a milk carton with water in it and a um
two two like lemon juices
and does he just hit those raw the lemon
juice bottles yeah yeah he he like does
shots with them i i was thinking can we
see can we see here we go here
[Music]
dude even shoenice would be struggling
with that
wow
what a showman
what a showman
i i was thinking for a video idea
actually once to douche lemon shots with
wally
for one of our video ideas wait have you
i don't know have you not tried it yet
tony
dude i don't want i i've tried to drop
listen
everyone here has tried it we all tried
it
they held it they killed battles
[Music]
and you will not should they not go
outside because every toilet you go use
bottom they clean your stomach
and how many valve movements are we
making per day wally what's your
schedule
how often do you go to the bathroom
wally poop though
when they eat this food and they cut it
and
he's asking about about you like how
often do you go to the bathroom
every day okay
and and i don't want to answer that
wait you don't want to answer that like
he was asking
how many times a day do you go to the
bathroom
[Music]
the morning or afternoon uh maybe a
twice time maybe one time
okay once or twice a day
yeah
what's his about what's his uh movement
quality like is it we talking hard or
soft or it varies by day
wally this year
do you have any if you have too much
driving
just drink something up to
[Music]
there you go
and so let me let me get a close-up of
that table there let's see what's on the
table
oh that one yeah that one there
yeah uh what is this wally this is the
coffee coffee yeah
okay
what's in all those bags there
oh he's just sometimes i don't i don't
even oh
okay we got some uh we got some toilet
paper here
okay what's the toilet paper for wally
you know the thing wheel
okay he cleans the table with this one
okay okay okay
magnifying glass do we use that actively
uh he used it to read this document
that
about his citizenship i'm actually
driving him to uh
this lawyer's office on tuesday next
week
because um
yes it is like citizenship
uh renewed or something like green card
probably yeah
yeah i guess something like that oh well
that's no no no i left my city here the
army is stopped in the fourth house when
i come out the courts not they love they
give me they say
we give it back all people when you come
out probably don't show that probably
don't yeah yeah yeah yeah just leave it
can you can you hand in the magnifying
glass and have him put him up to his eye
i want to see what that looks like
[Applause]
can he hold that up to his eye and do
like the
wally sounds for me
go ahead yeah just hold over his eye if
we could
a little higher a little higher
yeah right there right there a little to
the left
yeah
thank you wally that was beautiful
that was a powerful moment
okay what else we got where can we see
the bathroom
yeah yeah there's more stuff there's
more uh so over here he has this like
ac area i i actually haven't opened this
but let's take a look
no bodies right okay
let's let's see
okay it's empty okay just an empty
closet afraid i don't see some arabs in
there
yeah i thought i was going to see like a
few like dead people
all right okay there's another one right
here can i open this okay
all right
no i'm just kidding no i'm just doing
nothing came out
ah he
uh let's see what is this wally can i
open these uh
little drawers right here go ahead
okay wait let's see let's take it
all right i i don't know why there's a
there's a bag hanging out here okay
what's in the bag
like severed fingers or something i
don't know
take a look
uh this is uh
oh acts
i guess
clean all over so
hanging out it's all right
yeah hey wally wally stays clean yeah
nothing everything here is great the
man's got soap
he's got uh
jungles
that's just a scrub
oh [ __ ]
what is this
what does he use an air for
wally what is this for what is this
is this for your feet
oh it was there already so you don't
have anything to do with it what does it
say baby oil okay
i don't know what he uses that for
like john he doesn't need to tell us
dude he's he's too old for that
i don't think so
here's the bathroom okay nice nice no
problems here yeah
uh
you want to throw this throw it away oh
he's proving to us
uh
um
your friend tony said you're too old to
masturbate uh wally
wally do you play with your penis no no
no that's that's that's that's rude i
didn't ask her like that come on
no
nothing okay
i'm not caught
he's a christian boy he does not uh
touch he's good i told you he's good
he's good i didn't ask it like that but
well okay right to the point right to
the point and that that's what we love
all right
i don't i don't know what this is for
yes that's for like toilet paper uh the
floor is a little bit wet
um
the the toilet is really low to the
ground
like really really low to the ground
that you can
i don't know can you can we can we go
visit the uh bedroom now
yeah his bedroom's empty like it has
nothing in it oh where does he sleep
right there on his couch oh wow wow wow
wow
he has a uh shopping shopping cart yeah
he's stolen a shopping cart fantastic
yeah yeah so uh we basically um when we
go shopping i take this outside and i
put all the stuff that we like bought he
he buys like a shitload of like bulk
stuff right
like lemon and beans and all that stuff
and he buys like tons and tons of
freaking like
stuff like hacks of this stuff like
by the time we're done like putting it
all in this thing it's like up to here
all right
his house looks really clean i gotta say
i got a props to that
can you go tell wally that the um
gofundme is now over
four thousand one hundred dollars
thank you
four thousand one hundred and fifty
dollars wally
thank god thank you god bless you my
friend
god bless you everyone god bless you my
friend
um
all right well
oh there's a few more things i want to
ask just can can he get a clean
soundbite of him saying this is wally p
and you're watching the h3 podcast
say what he just said
what
say it again
can you say this is wally p and you're
watching the h3 podcast
this is wally t you uh watch your a
space
he can't say three it's really hard for
me yeah just say just do your best it's
fine
because my throne is so jealous
big tongue
when he talks about you he says hbhb
yeah that's right
yeah that's fine
can he just do one more clean one for us
because i actually really want to just
say he could say abh bhb whatever say
this is wally p and you're watching the
h3 podcast
all right there you go
thank you
wait um
oh can you do me a favor and say you
should i ask him to say that is that too
much jan thoughts dance dance
[Music]
i have one question for y'all
if that's all right absolutely
um
uh where what um i heard that you just
now you just recently had a second child
ethan that's right
and is that why elo's not there
uh nope she doesn't do uh wednesday
episodes
oh cause she's she's working on
something else
oh
yes sorry i know he's probably one of
the business nowadays so you probably
you probably preoccupied with that
and uh another question that i had this
is just a personal question from me um
after this that whole nra thing and all
that like do you still go out and shoot
guns like i saw you made a video with
idubbbz once on your main channel
about shooting
you like i mean i don't i don't use on
guns now
um well i've been pretty vocal about it
so
i think most people probably know my
opinion on guns you know we need more
gun control there's nothing wrong with
it
yeah wally what's your question
why wasn't i in the hospital
you didn't like that in the hospital why
i see in the teacher somebody sent him a
picture of you like flipping off the
camera at a hospital i guess something
like that and you put your fingers like
that why
oh
you were giving the finger in the
hospital oh was that when i was getting
the iv or i
think so no i think recently you posted
a [ __ ] your finger under uh
under a tweet
you know
it's very much like joe biden you go to
hell it's just a joke you know what i
mean
yeah
yeah you understand that right
[Music]
and one one more thing while we've got
you here can does he want to unpack this
um
this bit he was doing with the clown
filter was was pretty iconic this is the
first video of his i saw
um
for the culture
right
but you asked joe biden if they put iran
down iran down syria
we've been given 65 and 60 of oil on
patrol for the usa for the likely that
would be put the guard got
priced 25 cents a gallon
right
so
um is there anything else i don't know
that will have this opportunity again
no you will trust me i come here really
like often okay but is there anything
else you guys want to ask before we sign
off i just i wanted to make it clear to
wally that i that we tried his lemon
garlic flagel uh concoction that he
said fixes kovid right
was it wasn't that that's the kovic
you eat pork beef chicken any kind of
food just eat garlic and onion and see
that anytime garlic onions
are sick you know maybe you go for the
sodium
and cheese
wally whereas
[Applause]
god bless you my friend god bless you
maybe it goes to ten thousand dollar i
buy the call and i buy the food
oh you get it all you get it all right
all right well i'm gonna you know
thank you so much
it's been a true pleasure and very
interesting as well and we're going to
try to get a hold of jimmy lee and try
to figure out if there's a way we can
get uh
yeah thank you for a b in christina and
uh
danny mark in ireland capital
and
uh
[Music]
thank you for all of them thank you god
bless you yeah god bless you is there
anything he wants to tell the world
there's thirty six thousand people
watching
ready
well we're going to sign out right now
so is if there's anything you want to
tell the world are we just going to is
he good he's done
wally say thank you god bless you jewish
and christian any one day now on the
live
and god bless you professional good son
and goddess you usa
and god bless you any kanye christian
and
every country
can i get a god can i can i get it god
bless you to the muslims of the world
god bless you it's not you but i know
how many problems
that was good that's progressing
my family passed
yes okay
well i think we made progress here today
we gotta god bless you to the
to the
to the muslims didn't we or the arabs
are feeling a little blessed yeah that's
good that's progress where this progress
this is good
thank you tony for making this possible
thank you wally
uh for coming out here
whammily whammily whammily that's what
people are saying in the chat
by the world again i put the quran in
the ground i threw a bunch
and that's why i put the quran in the in
the bathroom that's why so you put the
quran in in like the toilet what did you
do with the quran
because
they put a stop
my mother passed away yeah and my
daughters passed away my brothers
and they put the staff and not seeing it
and um
once they said the journey they put the
sub nasty you know my family say you did
it i'm not good my family that's why no
more talk with no people back with my
sister analysis but no one talked with
me they say you did it but ahmed they
did it but not me
there you have it uh there there you
have it
well
wally take care
and uh we'll talk to you soon so thank
you both all right
thank you
everyone and uh live
god bless god bless god
[Applause]
yeah youtube thank you everyone they're
live youtube
thank you thank you
all right go ahead you can yeah good
thank you
wow
wow
a moment 18 months in the making
you know i had a
if i could understand a little better i
think the back story could have been
like fascinating but i did the best i
could you did the best you could you
know but definitely an interesting guy
and uh
i mean not many people can chug
lemon juice like that
certainly
but uh we've certainly i mean we
he doesn't like muslims that we learned
is kind of the
uh yeah i mean i don't love that through
a lot
he is a man who from what i could gather
entire family was killed by saddam
hussein's regime right he was tortured
in prison camp for 10 years
uh you know
obviously he is being
a little bit uh generalizing by um a
little bit muslim people for that and
that's not that's not very enlightened
that's not uh necessarily a good thing
but um
my family wasn't killed and i didn't
spend 10 years in a prison camp and so
that level of trauma is something that
you know
but what can you really are you guys uh
we are good me and i were cracking up
this whole time yeah i didn't think i
wanted him on here probably just as much
as dan zach all of us i really wanted to
get him on here yeah it's about the meme
guys yeah i knew i knew you're gonna
take it personally thank you though
i mean
you know
it comes from a place of of her and it's
not personal yeah happy birthday
yeah you love me yeah you wish me happy
birthday so
dan on the other hand
not a fan of
go ahead zach
don't leave me hanging
yeah
well that was well was it worth the wait
i'd say yes
and on a plus side on a positive note
we've managed to raise
a good
almost five let's see the grand total
for our boy muhammad
wally
almost five thousand man he hit his goal
he's only 250
dollars away from getting his goal
how cool is that
there's going to be a lot of beans in
his future i hope so yeah
and yeah um
i'm uh
appreciative that uh i had talked to to
tony a little bit um before the show as
well
and
yeah it from what i can gather
he was just a fan that like he explained
found out that he lived close to wally
and once he reached out to him um
you know he's kind he he didn't really
have to do any of this but he's in the
right place
look tony said next week he's taking him
to do meetings he's taking him out to do
meetings he's helping him go shopping
and get food that's honestly a really
good thing and uh that's ridiculously
nice yeah
oh jimmy wants to call in are we ready
for well i was i was do you do you want
him to con out of the frying pan into
the fire as they say
well
let's see what else we got to talk about
i mean i was enjoying that jimmy lee
let's do a poll you guys want to
transition from that to jimmy lee i mean
i kind of wonder if we can ask jimmy if
he can do anything i would like to know
about the teeth thing but i have to say
wally didn't seem too keen
well i think because of the problems he
has he thinks i was having a hard time
understanding that but yeah it sounded
like he was essentially saying
he was hit repeatedly in the face as
part of his torture and it did some
serious damage to his jaw and without
reconstructive surgery it it's not so
simple for him to just get dentures you
know so it sounds like it's a pretty
complicated thing i would love to see
wally back in the day like a strapping
18 year old i wonder what he looks like
that's a good point i wonder if he has
any photos that'd be great hunk
um
but
let's we could have jimmy to talk about
what he could do for him
okay
it seems the the procedure he wants is
lipo stomach stapling but i know that
procedure is very
uh
involved very intense not easy right
i guess yeah let's bring jimmy on let's
just run this
episode into the ground side of the
mountain
it's off the rails baby it is off the
rails so
can't say we didn't warn you
um so you want me to uh
here i guess i'll give the link to you
zach yeah can you uh what's up i don't
know about you guys but i was enjoying
the jimmy lee street comedy it's just so
insane
personally i like it i don't know how
some of y'all just it's too much for you
i get
can we take a poll do you guys want more
do you guys want to finish the jimmy lee
um
saga
it seems very polar polarized here we
got a lot of absolute nose we got
tomatoes we got
yeses
let's see let's see what the people
think finish the jimmy lee saga yes yeah
get some feedback i have a bad pull but
it's a terrible pull
let's see
oh
thank you guys
67 yes
yeah as the crew described it when they
went out with him they called it trauma
bonding like we're all
experiencing this together so i think it
really is something special i i find it
endlessly fascinating guys i think it's
super entertaining i mean now one other
way of looking at this poll though
thirty percent a third of the people
watching right now don't want
i know i i i considered that dan that is
are you in that category dan of the
audience no i mean i i could go either
way
i mean we have a lot of other good
topics so i am a little
my my my
[ __ ]
uh austin mcbroom boxing update is
pretty epic
yeah that is good i mean my only concern
with bringing jimmy on is basically it's
kind of just trod and ground i mean
we've already
in great lengths i mean extensive
lengths pretty much as much as po
humanly possible explain to him all
right
what
is the issue with his street comedy and
uh he uploaded this yesterday yeah right
there's really not but you said there's
one particular part you like cam yeah
it's coming up um he goes inside a mall
or something no
that looks like he's right there i see
the hard rock okay so why don't we bring
jimmy on and
okay dan will you i'll just do a short
all right i'll give you the link will
you what's up though yeah let's just
watch the hard rack cafe part which i
heard was very good it's the highlight
just because
i know the behind the scenes of how how
all this went down he just walked in and
started recording like there's no uh
yeah it just bombs away yeah it was just
k and like
anything it was just
chaos well let's have a look there
without further ado
jimmy lee the jersey out of the hard
rock cafe we have our promo event
tonight with the press and the media so
i just want to let you know we're
actually going in now to meet press
media to promote our comedy television
show
dangerously funny which absolutely guys
isn't
[Music]
we're here for the jimmy lee uh roche
from the event tonight oh um yeah
i'll show you where you guys are okay
thanks wait she's taking him somewhere
for real that's probably the reservation
he probably put it down under the jimmy
lee roast under the jimmy lee rose he's
just at a restaurant yeah is that the
hard rock on hollywood so it's just like
a whole stick to make it seem like
there's an event there for him well
that's what he did last time
oh interesting exactly what he does yeah
and then he does it again in this video
i think three times
he keeps going into random restaurants
okay let's
let's check it out
okay
we're here at the hard rock cafe media
are coming any minute we're filming
everything it's coming to you live in
hollywood california at the hard rock
cafe how are you doing
how are you doing look at me man
good to see you how you guys doing how
are you doing everybody's going to be
here in a couple minutes
how are you doing everybody good how are
you doing good to see you thank you
thanks for coming coming through how you
guys doing thanks for coming good to see
you thank you we'll be we'll be filming
in a while guys just sit down that's
hilarious thank you aaron is in the
house what are you doing jimmy lee
family's just going up to random people
thank you thank you thank you for coming
thanks for coming out which is a
different take for him because he would
normally just go up to people and just
roast them so it's like he's like the
owner he's like the [ __ ] ace of the
club you know i'm super interested in
that shtick
thanks for coming out i'm the big star
thanks for coming here yeah appreciate
you he's on the campaign trail you're
meeting oh what a time we had at the
hard rock cafe with press and media it's
a wrap and we're on our way out
chicony's here we come
chikunis all right all right all right
i'm over
it in the lobby
oh jimmy's back
bring him on yeah hold it
this is off the rails what are we going
to do
audio audio i want to check audio audio
audio
audio
audio yeah
[Music]
all right jimmy is about ending
go on a3 podcast live brad you can watch
me
no go to h3 podcast and watch it live
but you can see
hey jimmy you hear me hey jimmy who who
are you talking to
i'm with cousin fred having dinner can
you hear me yeah i can hear you all
right hold on hold on honey
okay jersey outlaw right here ethan how
are you doing oh you switched the
glasses nice wait wait wait wait wait i
have to ethan
zach only wants me
like this
what
did you guys hear me okay
jimmy um i hear you okay
is is it too noisy do you want me to go
outside no it's i'm eating dinner in a
restaurant can i do it here audio's fine
the audio's
your audio is always great jimmy this
one audio
audio all right so thanks for uh having
me on yeah jimmy um
uh what is going on man you posted a
video yesterday that is just as bad as
all the other stuff
we've been
are we not getting through you
now you're getting through and by the
way
i did clean stuff on the chute the
problem is it doesn't work so when i was
editing with dave
he's like jim the stuff you do to be
nice and and clean and all that it
doesn't don't mind i'm eating who is he
i'm not sure
so
i did some of it and i did listen to you
but the problem is when we were editing
the people weren't laughing so we had to
revert back
did a classic stuff and
i i'm sorry if i offended anybody it
just it seems that seems to be
kind of what what works you know what i
mean the sun is so [ __ ] jimmy what are
you eating
[Laughter]
i'm eating i'm eating a roll oh
all right all right
a jewish danish roll
all righty
uh
um i'm at a seafood restaurant the last
time ethan i came here i got the shrimp
but i came home with the crabs it was a
rough night i'm not going to do that
again
right
all right jimmy
so you think you'll be able to do some
prom do you think you'll be able to do
some free work for our boy wally
i'm going to take care of that out of my
respect to you
and my love for you and how much you
support me and love me i told zach yes i
will do that so i wonder so here's the
problem wally hey look yeah
wally lived by me because i'm in new
jersey yeah that's the problem he lives
in texas and he's in a mobility
chair and he has no way of traveling so
what can we do about that i'll drive
them oh that'd be great
well
that's
if somebody brought him to me i would
take care of him okay okay very far away
from me would you be would you be able
to pick him up in
of texas i would
drive
damn would damn would um damn would lift
them up into the car
and they'd be
i don't know what he would do he'd
probably wait
so i got to tell you
hold on hold on i see movie magic
h3 podcast exclusive
jimmy lee picks up wally
in a in a handicapped van it's like a
whole cross-country adventure jimmy drew
we're gonna do this like
i mean this could be huge
this could be huge jimmy
i think we need to do it wait you know
what i've been a good joke for you jimmy
a b can take care of the gas
that would have been a good joke for you
well let me tell you about it yeah
hey
he's a nice guy
he's a very nice guy i don't know where
he parked his camel but i hope it's in a
safe spot
are you barking
damn
jimmy
this man cannot
change hey fred can you get more
cocktail
[Laughter]
jimmy try the veal
try the veal he's pigging out right now
did you hear that one dancing we got
more cocktails maybe where'd you park
your camel or something could i get more
crosstalk
he was trying to outdo wally yeah great
everybody we just got off the phone with
an islamophobe for like an hour
be good cool
we got to get wally
we got to get wally to new jersey jack
i think zach is going to take the reigns
on that one here's what i'm thinking
zachary's doing it here's what i'm
thinking
jimmy i can
fly you out to texas or you can or i'll
i could pay for you to fly to texas if
you're a first class guy you can you
know pay for that yourself right
i could do my flight i can pay for your
flight
okay and then i'll rent a van
and then i'll rent a van okay
you hungry jimmy
storm yeah i can tell
um
why don't we find
dennis in fact and
[Music]
i'll fly out there and do a stretcher
there you can do that you can get it
temporary
you can get like a office to work out of
there i don't know any dentist in texas
we'd have to find a dentist and i don't
know anybody there that would have to be
zach's job that's what i'm that's what
i'm saying we'll probably have to bring
him to new jersey what about one of
those mobile dentistry vans
interesting like the mobile and then
jimmy could just no you need a gun for
doing
dentistry across the country on the way
down we could do comedy and dentistry i
think if zach isn't going to be on the
band with me
and jack and ethan we may have to do it
that way
zach and ethan all right but wait wait
wait wait wait wait everybody
let me flesh this out because i do think
there's something here
jimmy i'll fly you to texas to meet with
wally we'll rent you a van
uh with the handicap access to drive
cross country to new jersey we'll pay
for it all
and we'll catalog this beautiful journey
of these two men these two you guys will
become best friends come come comrades
you guys are gonna and and just and just
film and capture the whole journey
uh to the east okay and then ultimately
you get the you give him the teeth
watch it
i'm telling my cousin to watch the
podcast yeah
can i say hi to your cousin sure
freddie say hi to ethan
hey freddie can you hear me
no but if you say something i'll tell
them what you said i just say just say
freddy
just say freddie are you i want to say
to freddie say are you embarrassed by my
street comedy
are you embarrassed
by my street company i've known i've
done gym since i'm three years old it's
the same routine
same routine growing up he said there
you have it
you want to ask him another one he's
right here ask him do you think jimmy
should
um
keep doing the street comedy or call it
a day he wants to know if i should quit
while i'm behind doing street comedy
he said absolutely quit
yeah go back to go back to the music
business
jimmy's actually a very talented
musician believe it or not zach says
you're very talented musician i wonder
why you made that segue from music to
comedy um i did it
yeah uh ethan by accident
giving her american music you know a
little comedy booker
and i asked him if i could do an open
mic and that was that was it right there
jimmy can you do me a favor
can you put the phone in the bread
basket
[Music]
like that yeah and then just put a piece
of bread right in the so there's a
little bread in the frame
yeah but put it down
[Music]
so it feels like i'm in your bread
basket i want the pov
to be that i'm in your bread basket
do you know what i'm saying
is that it right there no put the phone
down inside the bread basket don't hold
it i whatever you say ethan i
then put put a bread covering the camera
halfway
okay like that no but looking up at the
ceiling
like it's you know what i mean
like that
yeah yeah
what is it
is that what is that what's that
supposed to do
it just
it's just a vibe jimmy it's a comedy
thing you won't get it jimmy you're
making a spectacle of yourself
no you said that
that was zack of course
who said that zach yeah
can we get a more close-up as you chew
as you chew your food get the camera
right in your mouth
say bingo freddie no let loud bingo
scream so the whole restaurant gets
scared
can you can you scream
uh hold on do it as loud as you can
is he doing street comedy in the
restaurant
on the phone jimmy
i'm a famous
celebrity i'm on a podcast there's like
50 000 people watching play lady is a
[ __ ]
with them i'm getting hollered out here
too zach tell them you want jimmy lee
say we want jimmy lee
i'm gonna oh everybody
i think zach we got we got booted zach
who jimmy who are these people
lillian
plays the piano yeah these are
these are guests at the bar i i come
here all the time and eat are you ready
i'm gonna put a tip in the tip jar
jimmy lee the jersey apple is a funny
guy
it jimmy do you know those people
yeah i come here a lot okay this is a
place my dad used to go so so would you
go to a table
would you go do some straight comedy to
a table of people that don't know who
you are
let's do it
all right leave the people alone you
asked for it how are you guys doing
you're on tv
behind the scenes
you you like don rickles
do you like insult comedy
you know what paul revere said no at the
boston tea party what do you say he said
see we got plenty of coffee we need
where are you from
we bury your tuesday throw dirt on your
wednesday and what what's your name
what's your name
suzanne
abandon north carolina you're good so
you're on you're on tv right now there's
a podcast so thanks for uh dinner don't
get the shrimp you'll go you'll go home
with the crabs take care jimmy go take a
piece of their food
he's got the oxygen tank just in case
[Laughter]
let me let me get it in they're going to
tear his nose down a little shopping
center
and uh
hold on zach how you doing
this is lady kazam from 1972 now now
she's uh eating
jimmy can i make an observation give a
shout out to zach say zach give him a
bingo bingo no do it bingo
bingo
hey nobody's better than the jersey
outlaw jimmy can i make an observation
you asked for it like jimmy jimmy jimmy
i don't know if he can hear me he's just
he's jimmy jimmy he's in his house
he's off the rails outlaw here
okay can i ask can i ask your cousin
what did he think about that
what do you think about what i just did
fred i have no idea i'm just sitting
here
we're friends uncle fred is he's
embarrassed he didn't follow me around
no of course not that's that's huge more
of sense than that that was horrifying
and you got good job
thank you
what'd you think zacharoonie zack
meister was that good jackie baby chef's
kiss
do you feel embarrassed at all or no
no i like all this crap i got it i got
personality disorder remember we
mentioned that three weeks ago
that's the whole problem when you took
the hook and you said get the hell off
that's the funniest thing i ever heard i
love this crap i have a personality
disorder
holy [ __ ] man well you went through this
uh remember yeah no exactly i just love
the way you put it there 86 times don't
don't forget that no i will never
jimmy i me can i make an observation
i got personality disorder no no no no
it just seems that you're making fun of
all the people there who are old but you
seem to be those people seem to be your
contemporaries do you think it seems to
be that innocent older people get my
jokes from my contemporaries what do you
say to that fred
you hit it on the head i'm just saying
that that whatever restaurant you're at
seems to attract a specific crowd and
you might be a member of that crowd is
all i'm saying jimmy do you need to show
an arp card to get in there
don't don't be so pushy because right
now i'm doing the free denture right
don't be pushy
well that's a humanitarian effort come
on give me i'm doing a wonderful thing
i did a wonderful thing for uh las vegas
uh ethan i left
yeah that was nice
i'll get to the funny ones a little
later do you want me to go bother the
piano lady and aggravate her nail no no
no i think we need to aggravate lillian
and get him pissed you don't have to do
that oh she's rushing she's rushing
should we get him to put his finger in
someone's water no
i'd like to see him eat a piece of food
if i'm being
exactly like
fred what do you order
he got soft shells i got the flounder
yeah
once in a lifetime zack is requesting
that you
no eat food take a piece of food off
someone's plate you don't know on the
restaurant is this like uh practicing
practical jokers it might be yeah i mean
yeah yeah take food out of the hand of
them
they have a request for me to eat some
of your food no why this guy again
oh my god he goes up to the guy he knows
he can't
no jimmy he's got to be a random guy
jack jack
whoa
what do you do for your job
do uh what do i do i don't do nothing
anymore what was your line of work what
did you do i real estate the real estate
guy real estate guy
all right you're a nice guy tonight's
out the trick-or-treat it's about three
months from now trick-or-treat charlie
jimmy
jimmy jimmy say hi to ethan from h3h
street what's up how you doing tell them
your name aaron eric eric where are you
from earth
mexico it's max circle let's
[Music]
this is crazy man you've been going
there a long time but that might be your
last time
yeah i'm gonna get 86 man
[Laughter]
what's your name
john you got a nice outfit it's a nice
tie you're making a fool of himself
that's not a joke
that doesn't stop
where's jack happy purim say happy
portland
happy purim to zach
what's your name
[Laughter]
it is let's go
here we go into the kitchen i can't
[Laughter]
how are you my friend everybody's papers
make sure we're good jimmy go cook
something good for my next four through
the morning
we go back to the porn zach bernstein
the mexican jewel you don't know if he
wants to steal around the bank
okay let's get
yeah i'm gonna tell you that another
time can you come out
hey take a bite say hello to say hello
to the salad girl what's your name hun
what's your name
amy you married amy because zack's
looking i'm not jack's looking
jewish guy plays the guitar at night not
very well but he plays the guitar at
night
pepe it's pepe hello pepe there he is
you've got a whole
if you're watching this later we're
sorry ethan hillary that's you're on say
hi to ethan are you serious
that's awesome
trevor's here
shout out trevor
i gotta get out the throwing me out yeah
oh cool trevor
who who's got the balls to do this zach
who's got only
only you only you only a person with
severe mental illness could uh
somebody with histrionic personality
disorder can pull his soul out that's it
that's it
audio audio audio jesus christ oh my god
that wasn't everybody are you back
wait are you ready for the piano yet oh
my god okay everyone's chill everyone
relax just relax jimmy let's just tone
it down i want to ask you some questions
everyone just just bring it down turn it
down
okay lil you ready no
all right liliana blew me out that's the
end of liliana
you're still maybe go back to your seat
i'm coming deep down what's up kids
all right let me talk to your cousin
tell him i took my pill
there's cousin fred no
there's no pill
yeah so so fred
so fred what did you think about all
that and be honest with me
fred what do you think about the kitchen
thank god i wasn't in there as long as
they're making my food that i'm doing
okay
as long as he wasn't involved and was
fred begging you to stop to leave that
waiter alone no freddie's known me since
i'm a kid he knows i've been doing this
since then i'll ask frank he was three
ask fred
what since you were about nine or ten
and i'm about three years right so what
am i asking ted
you were asking him was he begging you
to leave the waiter alone
did you want me to leave the waiter
alone
i let him do it
hold on
he's getting bitched out
i don't want any trouble for you that's
the whole thing it's okay
oh you're working i wasn't sure you were
here
i know you played a piano
i didn't make fun of me and but the
notes on the piano don't go that low
he's still going you play
all right so what just happened
what just happened fred what just
happened
he said liliana looked a little a little
pissed or a lot
no but is lit liliana the piano since
the uh
is lily but ever since the uh
[Music]
the russians get moody now ever since
the goddamn war started they want to
take the whole goddamn world over jimmy
stop stop stop jimmy stop
i'm done thank you was that the piano
player who was that
that's liliana the pianist she's a
little steamed up right now and what was
she
and she was mad that you are
interrupting or playing yeah
correct
right kind of addiction
little chopsticks that's all we wanted
to do didn't work
you want to do a little duet
[Music]
you and zach what are you talking about
dan
first of all
was the one that said go to the kids and
definitely the moment he said go get
food i was just relaying what zach said
don't talk about i'm afraid i'm afraid
your cousin fred is enabling you
um
sometimes we have a cousin like that
they just gotta let them go off there's
nothing you can do
does fred ever think about hosting an
intervention or anything like that
killing himself when he's with me yes
fred do you want to host an intervention
for me
it will work
it won't work he says it won't work
that's true fred's like i mean we did
that we basically did a whole episode
doing an intervention
[Laughter]
okay you know what jimmy
give me
my meals here wait no no jimmy jimmy
jimmy jimmy jimmy
there's one more thing i need you to do
i need you to do something
can you please
can you please go apologize to all the
peoples whose dinner you interrupted
that's not the jersey
jimmy please go do that it's just right
here
for the podcast i'd appreciate you don't
want to do any apologies
well i think they oh you know h3 say hi
to ethan what's up ethan how's it going
hey dude he's a fanny
that's cool
can i get a side of butter
are you a chinese guy
how you doing
little little last start to the column
okay
please jimmy do what ethan says go
apologize please just quickly just
quickly
do you want me to really apologize yes
and so freddie said it's over now
the people are cool they know me here
i'm a regular uh for real like i come
here a lot okay but maybe maybe just
apologize maybe just apologize to the
piano lady she seemed upset
okay hold on yeah
speaking of interesting
just a quick just a quick apology we
don't want your fish to get cold
good guy jimmy
lou i want to apologize for before i'm
sorry seriously
i was zoey
i'm sorry
i apologize
crazy
sorry
you too all right i think she liked fred
we apologize
that was good that was nice
didn't that feel good
ah
well she's known me a long time i sat
and played the piano with her many
occasions so it's she didn't like me
being disrespectful that's all i think i
think if you led with i have a
personality disorder people would
understand the jokes wait did he did you
interrupt her playing the piano
sounds like it that's what zach asked me
to do i didn't ask you to do that
i would never have you do that from one
musician to another no no no no no no i
didn't know she was playing the piano
well either way
i mean him running around the restaurant
like a maniac was probably hillary
yeah let's take a look at i think that's
a better skit than the real
yeah i would say so let's see let's see
the plate
all right
try the veal
can i eat zach because my food's gonna
get cold
yeah why don't you enjoy your meal okay
it was nice catching up with you jimmy
clearly i love you guys and ethan if the
guy honestly
can get here i can do them it's hard for
me to go to texas i mean on a serious
note i don't mind doing something for
really nice so maybe we can maybe we can
rent him a van or a van and and uh
if you came here to new jersey i would
do it free for you because i love you
guys and you're very nice to me okay
well maybe what we should start with is
we can get some picture of his teeth
over and you can kind of see
what you can even do for him you know
okay i would do that for you
so let maybe we can get a diagnosis from
you
i don't come and eat the end of july if
um
your dad wants you to do a little thing
yeah
yeah do it yes yes
we should
says it's okay i'm not the boss jimmy uh
oh
could i get an ice cream
say hi to zach
what's up tell him what you told me that
he's a lousy guitar player
[Laughter]
[Music]
love you jim jim will fix it
all right i will and guys on it
seriously wait isn't that the pedophile
show
jimmy will fix it that's the veils show
oh was that what it was called i don't
know all right take care jimmy
not not talking about you we were we're
talking about the other jimmy all right
thanks
thank you dan
all right
that was unexpected and totally off the
rails
yeah i don't think there's any there's
no changing jimmy you know
um
personality disorder imagine a six hour
day of that
you know
that was so wild
how does cousin just endure all that
i've just probably just used to it i
mean 50 years of that
i have like a tummy ache
i've been anxious about that
it's pretty overwhelming right there um
by the way i'm seeing people point out
in the chat and this is a good point
that um if uh wally's on probation he
can't leave texas oh no
jim will have to go we learned a lot he
went on a police chase i mean how epic
is that you guys
from wally to jimmy this is just off the
road this is the most off the rails the
show's ever been so hmm so what he said
in a couple of weeks i think he said
five months he said in a couple weeks
he's off probation maybe five weeks okay
so here's what i want to do
let's find out when he's off probation
in the meantime let's get some pictures
of his mouth some close-ups maybe tony
can help us and get those to jimmy so we
can get a diagnosis
and a game plan and see if this is
something that either of them you know
even wants because wally was kind of
lukewarm i think on the idea
well it sounded like he had explored it
in the past and was given
a significantly difficult diagnosis and
he just seemed kind of like
well i think jimmy can do i think
jimmy's going to be able to do something
for him
oh the chat saying four months four
months i'm hearing
tony to confirm i'm hearing four five
and six months in the chat and 12. yeah
he can ask for permission from his
probation officer to leave someone said
too for the dental work right i guess
yeah he might be able to get a pass for
something like that um i'm seeing a lot
of people say this is the most hilarious
episode ever i appreciate you saying
very polar reactions i think all
the people that mccree have left by now
is part of the reason that we're seeing
that i'm seeing lots of people who love
it and lots of people that hate it
i mean guys whatev whatever your action
is nobody can deny that that was off the
rails it was off the rails this is the
name of the show unplanned
no plan for this
well how long we've been going we got a
lot of stuff here left we've been going
for two hours and 49 minutes so let's
see here we got um
we've got
well this girl who put herself in the
hospital selling farts
it was like a 90 day fiance thing right
well she's moved on
to she's selling
boob sweat
and this actually is a she's kind of an
innovator [ __ ]
yeah boobs what's a new one by the way
here's jimmy lee
in the kitchen and cooking up trouble
work with me
that was [ __ ] crazy man uh holy [ __ ]
all right tony just confirmed four
months for the probation okay okay so
that's so that's good that'll give us
some time to start planning
but yeah this will be very nice
oh
so let's take a look at stephanie
yeah she was farting so much in the jar
she had to go to the hospital
it ain't easy work she says but no one
said it would be never thought i'd have
this much in common with a maple tree
so excited to share these on my platform
i get so creative with what i do there
let's take a look
day in the life making thousands of
dollars selling my tata sweat
in bottles
do you know what i like about her
i believe her when she's selling boobs i
believe that she's actually doing it
because she was so committed to farting
in the jar that she actually went to the
hospital amaranth friend of the show i
like her i'm not convinced she's farting
in those bottles
this girl i think you're getting the
real thing see some titties
i can't
believe i mean i smelled it it smelled
nothing all of us smelled it it was
maybe it leaked in transportation i
can't believe you won't give her the
benefit of the doubt the hair was in
there though
yeah yeah that's easy do you not think
if it was fake it would have like
smelled
a lot
i don't think there's anything in it
right if you're going to fake it you
would put in something like that
she's smart she's smart she knows she
does she can't just put sulfur in there
i don't and listen it's just a hunch
because she's so busy but this girl i'm
just saying i think i think she's really
delivering
just saying and how is she collect oh
that's it
how much is a bottle of boobs what i
think i've got it here it's uh 500 bucks
500 bucks good deal
[ __ ] yes the farts were a thousand
right exactly so that's actually kind of
a steal i mean she says it takes 15
minutes for her to sweat enough
to store it in her jar
with boob sweat i want to do the right
thing she said i want to be smart and
start off slow
and have sustainable growth that doesn't
overwhelm her body
unlike of course the farts right
so papa john's gonna be getting on that
maybe be a good birthday present what do
you get a man who has it all
a jar of boob sweat
that's what they always say yeah
yeah yeah they do say that don't they
they do
really beautiful so johnny depp made a
tick tock i'm afraid to talk about this
because if i say anything critical of
johnny johnny
i'll get buried
i'll get absolutely buried
he could start a cold at this point if
i'm being totally honest
to all my most treasured loyal and
unwavering supporters
we've been everywhere together
we have seen everything together we have
walked oh he did the countdown like the
dungeon video yeah we have walked the
same road together we did the right
thing together all because you cared and
now
we will all move forward together you
are as always my employer
and once again i'm
whittled down to
no way to say thank you is that a good
impression
because
pretty good actually other than just
by saying
thank you
and so
oh thank you
my love and respect johnny human fecal
matter human fecal matter
let's watch the video
what whoa he up he uploaded the kfc ad
no it's just tick tock is [ __ ]
that's unexpected well that killed good
good tick tock yeah with this countdown
and everything i was not expecting that
i love you johnny
yes
oh yes
oh yes
he looks like he wears a lot of clothes
like just a lot of layers you know what
i mean
it feels like he'd be hot in all those
layers
you know what i'm saying
sure it's not that bad i i don't know
it's like cool dude he like
he dipped like he wasn't even there for
the verdict and he's like on [ __ ]
stage with jeff back well you know what
if he doesn't need to be there then [ __ ]
it he already wasted enough life in
court no i'm just gonna live his life
it's a badass move he's like i'm gonna
go [ __ ] play with jeff beck yeah [ __ ]
it 21 million
did he already get um rehired for
pirates i heard that is that true i
heard that too
i'll find out damn johnny is back
dropped a uh
grumpy
dropping a grumpy grumpy it's pretty
incredible how he's just back
you know even though
i think the jury made the right call
it was
i'm sorry anyone interrupt go ahead i
should say they said that they would
consider bringing them back a past
disney exec that's all i'm seeing but
nothing confirmed they'd be insane not
to i mean it's going to be gangbusters
yeah johnny said he would never work
with disney again oh really i don't know
if that's happening
oh but that would be such a good
you know that movie would make a billion
dollars oh for sure
and you know even though i agree with
the jury and
johnny was right to win that case i was
actually and i was saying from the
beginning
i didn't think he was going to win
because defamation is so hard to prove
so
it must have really
it's very very very hard to win a
defamation case and the fact that he won
means that you know
they really had a slam dunk case
so
but all that being said it is just the
whole thing is pretty sad because
you already see it happening now
um where it's like don't all women don't
believe all women uh which is true i
mean believe all women is kind of a
weird premise but
um
but basically the result of this is just
gonna be
the metoo clock basically to deep to the
very default i mean it's like and it's
amber of herd's fault right it's not
even johnny depp's fault i'm not blaming
him
i mean she's the one that wrote this
[ __ ] article and they proved she
defamed him so it's just a shame that
something like this can set everything
back because already it's just
deflection like see she lied
they lied about me he lied about me and
it's just like you know
it's it's unfortunate and sad
that um
so much progress was was rewound
by this but i mean and ultimately good
for johnny right
and uh johnny johnny yes papa
eating sugar no papa
it's rewind time telling lies
no papa
open your mouth hahaha
grumpy
people are saying it empowers the metoo
movement i don't know how that
because i already see that like
people view johnny depp as a victim of
domestic violence at this point is i
think what they mean by that okay um so
good for victims victims one people are
saying right
okay
i think it's complicated what you're
saying is not invalid i mean i've seen
it too yeah there are lots of men's
rights activists that are taking this as
a huge dub so yeah i mean it's not
incorrect and it's people like john
donald trump jr and donald trump being
like you see my 15 accusers are all
liars
exactly
you know
i made a tweet i made a joke on twitter
like even harvey weinstein's coming out
making statements seen see i'm innocent
too
but you know everything should be uh
examined on a case
by case basis
so
this is good for men i hear people say
uh him too oh [ __ ] we need a him too
okay
uh well
i don't know
well we're gonna see these welcome to
tick tock johnny johnny yes papa see
what right below this bonus cringe
what in the discord brody can you guys
i mean here exactly
dear all journalists who wrote this
article's defending amber heard slies
it's like what are you talking about who
wrote those articles
in a full censure by the way wait didn't
you copy keemstar oh yeah you gotta show
that you gotta show that is that in the
dark i just sent it dude this guy is
such a [ __ ] lunatic
he posted this
first of all i don't
i i have keemstar blocked i have nothing
to do with him
and then i forget what was the context
but
this was during my goblin era when i was
during all my suspension
and i was like taking a [ __ ] and
flipping off to show just how much i
don't give a [ __ ] right irreverent i
believe is the word just like you know
listen guys it's just who i it's just
who i am
anyway keemstar literally tweets this
which is so embarrassing
10 minutes later he copies me keep in
mind he has me blocked
weirdos stalking me on all accounts
i wouldn't even have seen this but fans
tweeted me he copied me
dude looks like a retired ronald
mcdonald
fyi he's four years younger than me i
mean first of all dude this i mean since
when does age matter to you
[Laughter]
right
first of all it's so weird that he
actually thought this was not
embarrassing to tweet
like dude literally flipping the camera
off is like
i think every that's like what everybody
does in every photo since the beginning
of no photography wrong
keem invented
the middle finger gesture
so he says he's copying me
how pathological do you have to be
do you think
he thinks that you're copying him for
having a nose and eyes and
hands
apparently he's copying my human form
not my human form
i'm the platonic ideal of a human being
and ethan is but
i mean a copy of a copy of a copy this
is so embarrassing to say that he would
and basically he admit he's stalking me
on alt
which is what he accused me of bro i
don't check your tweets i don't give a
[ __ ] i blocked you because you're
annoying and [ __ ] i don't want to
think about you on twitter stupid [ __ ]
but this is so embarrassing
he also he also thinks seems to think
that he looks super youthful which is
kind of funny you look younger than him
he says fyi he's like four years younger
than me no i'm not going to say i look
great for my age but i don't understand
what makes you think you look so
youthful bro his entire face is covered
literally 80 percent of his face is
covered
right
he's covering his bald head he has a
dyed beard a very poorly dyed beard and
the biggest [ __ ] sunglasses you can
possibly get
much of his face is possible i'm not
trying to hide my face or anything i'm
actually quite comfortable
with who i am and what i look like but
like dude if you're i didn't that might
be 90 coverage that's a young looking
lip
yeah check that out man he's so youthful
she's so youthful i mean bro you think
you look so useful let's see your face
what the [ __ ] you talking about
terrorist you literally are showing a
sliver of your forehead
your nose and one lip
one you're
you're literally
you
it's just so ironic that you're covering
your whole [ __ ] face bro
in your own house by the way this is you
in your house like hey i'm just casually
in my house covering 90 of my face
you're so embarrassed by how you look
you literally can't even look at
yourself in the mirror in your own home
without covering 90 of your face
you're such a little [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that was that you was
olivia
oh was that from it was yeah yeah
thank you gasper by the way for 10
gifted subs love appreciate
yeah
i mean listen i'm not gonna [ __ ] i'm
not i don't pro
pro claim my beauty okay
trust me on that
but
you are not a picture of youth bro
i mean
at all
terrorist
terrorist
so there's a ribbon i just thought that
tweet was like next level even for him
there you have it
little keemstar update there for you
it's fun
but i i won't say anything bad about
johnny depp
we stand unconditionally for johnny depp
isn't that right guys
[Applause]
nah
there once was a man named johnny depp
who took the stand we won't forget the
roles he's played in the pirates play
that made a childhood
soon may the justice comes whoever goes
back to where she came from one day when
the trial is done he'll take his money
and go
there once was
bro this is more cringe than [ __ ]
jimmy later
you gotta stop this
this is embarrassing bro
walking in on my husband singing this
someone said
this is not okay okay free johnny depp
and all that but like you you bro come
on
i'm sorry but it's too much
oh
there's another one
the sheet the sea shanty number two huh
we now invite captain jack sparrow to
the stand
stop it
objection here say objection overruled
mr sparrow please continue
there once was a girl who made a turd on
the bed and her name was amber heard she
made stuff up to bring john
to court they go
soon may the verdict come that amber's
lying out her bum will drink a mega
pints of rum when johnny's free to go if
it wasn't enough to soil the bed she
cuts off his finger and bashed his head
on the door and yet she still said she
couldn't hurt him so
soon may the verdict come that amber
stop laughing not funny
i can't [ __ ] say anything about this
[ __ ]
so just get mad at me
listen okay amber johnny whatever you
believe uh
i'm sorry that happened to you or
whatever i don't know
happy for you or sorry to happen yeah
okay let's talk about austin mcbroom
this guy has the balls to be putting on
another boxing event through social
gloves is that not the best thing oh
he's the king and you know what
if like idubbbz fought austin that'd be
[ __ ] great
first of all what is this like red dead
redemption ass looking this is the worst
[ __ ] post i've ever seen i couldn't
believe what i was saying
bro what is this
it's like a page of the torah or
something
like what the [ __ ]
honestly i i'm i'm not even going to
read this bro oh we did did you guys get
the folder yeah it's in there it's in
there so we worked we were talking about
this on uh
in the podcast and so we decided that
we'll make uh too long didn't read for
you guys
because who the [ __ ] going to read
it was in our group chat and you said
i ain't reading all that [ __ ] so cam
helped you out
is that the uh the album yeah it's in
there if you scroll down
oh it's here yeah you just scroll down
all right so so yeah obviously let's
just find out so here here's we kind of
edit it down i'm glad to say all the
fighters have been compensated
few that are pending due to them
potentially participating in the new
event why wouldn't you pay them if
they're participating in the new event
but okay
no that's probably he probably gave them
a deal
hey sorry we can't pay you but if you do
the next one i'll give you double what i
originally
who would take that
partly
part
some 17 year old tick tock star that
doesn't know any better and that and
that we are officially able to move
forward despite the less than expected
financial results of the lawsuits have
been resolved i lost out of my pocket
investing in the event
somebody said it looked like a dark
souls uh item description that's true
[Laughter]
stay tuned for my new fight in july
announcing the official day and my
opponent tomorrow i love that it's in
the lot july though like how much effort
are you putting into this bro literally
he's running two scams at once he's got
ace fest
and a boxing bat she's putting together
in one month
you said that edit was too long too so i
cut it down yeah i was like this is
this is not a good ethan just replied
too long still
so here's the one that said i lost out
of my own pocket investing in the event
and then i said well it's too long still
and so i lost
let's cut it down and then we said it's
too long it's still too long and we just
cut it down to
oh here's i lost we just cut it down to
l
so this is the ultimate too long didn't
read
boiling all this
i love that it's funny
oh man everyone wants to tell
everyone always wants to tell someone
else's story and create their own false
narrative well finally
i get to speak on it and put it to rest
okay
[ __ ]
dumbass i can't wait to go to ace fest
so this uh event though
this boxing tick tock boxing event is
here in l.a this time it's not in
florida like they always are
that's interesting no more talk nick
broome versus gibb now i don't give a
[ __ ] about this fight and if anyone's
wondering who gibb is
he fought jake paul and jake paul
knocked him out in the first round yeah
that was and it's like this it's just
not nobody had this fight there's hype
i'm so excited to see that guy the guy
who lost to jake paul i would 100 love
to watch austin fight like
anyone else but this i don't get
where they're doing it
yeah the crypto.com arena crazy
crippling isn't that where they had
their
scam thing last time yeah the one with
chris brown there's no [ __ ] way
they're going to sell out that stadium
this is insane
we got to send someone there
we're going to buy the cheapest tickets
so i'm not gonna pay them oh come on i
think uh absolutely
give him make broom a run for his money
um
i don't know i remember you're saying in
a fight yeah they have boxing he's an ad
he's pretty big yeah he's very athletic
nazis that you wouldn't you wouldn't be
able to put up a fight but i don't think
i do think he's a he's a he's not super
tall no he's about my he's like all
right but and my age wait i thought he
was tall because he's a basketball i
think he's six feet tall
because bryce hall isn't he was a
college basketball player he was he
wasn't an nba or anything still you got
to be tall to play
i think he's only like six feet tall or
something
high six yeah six feet
well whatever in the ticket package that
we bought to ace fest it says watch
austin's next fight following ace family
fest includes you and your guests i
don't know like what that we haven't
even got the ticket what that means no i
literally still just have a receipt i
have no idea what to do with that maybe
we should email them be like yo where's
all this [ __ ] yeah like
well they said i would just show my
confirmation at the door yeah but how do
we watch this pay-per-view event then
which is apparently including right it's
evidently included but it just literally
says watches
watch his next fight i don't know it's
so weird so we gotta get
we gotta find out where's the full value
of the 500 ticket we bought
anyway another scam in the making
staples center that's awesome
man i never call in that place
crypto.com marino [ __ ] that's the
[ __ ] statement yeah damned
and crypto.com is going to be out of
business in a year well to be fair
sponsoring that that stadium is occurs
because staples really isn't uh in the
game anymore either well sure i mean
they're still around though at least
teddy fresh arena
oh okay
hell yeah street podcast arena
let's go
let's go
austin also appeared on tmz sports to
discuss the upcoming fight
he says
he wants to put on a show and do it the
right way
this is his
10th
event he's put on and scammed everyone
damned
let's see
you know with everything and how it went
down last june um what made you want to
try it again
that's a great question um
i feel like whenever you take on
challenges and risks um and everything
in life is supposed to be perfect
especially when you're you know trying
to do new business adventures
uh when you're a young entrepreneur
young entrepreneur you go through you
know trials and tribulations and that's
what we did the first time around um you
know we really did
you know uh do our due diligence and got
with the people for what we were trying
to do in the box in the boxing scene
this time around we're working with
people who been doing this for a while
um have a you know a new team
um new streaming partner don't care he's
going to lose a shitload of money
because nobody's paying to see that who
is his new partner i wonder
ace family aids family hat collection
he's hack collective
i had another thought about who it might
be
wait you think it's ryan kavkav yeah
triller wouldn't they say it was a
trailer event already i guess they
probably would have said that why the
[ __ ] would triller
like they're already such failures why
would they co-sign the biggest flop
in boxing history because of ryan
kavanaugh's incredible business acumen
like that that seems like a total ryan
cavanagh to be honest i'd be happy if i
was because i know they're going to lose
money so it's just one step closer to
him going bankrupt again
[Music]
there's no [ __ ] way trailer makes it
past like
the end of the year there's no way
i have to do a little digging on that
too much wine sorry
that's all right
what was the joke he said though
when he was too drunk to talk an
inappropriate relationship with a
four-year-old natalie porter oh [ __ ] no
that's not okay
it's weird
too much wine does not i'm the first jew
on stage in texas
jesus man what a degenerate drive angry
[Laughter]
this guy is just a lunatic
all right i guess we've been going for a
while now eh
yeah three hours 15 minutes my dude yeah
morbius is back in theaters
i just wish jared leto would stop
getting moved
roll the guy is just losing money for
every project he's in and he's so bad
he's just horrible actor he's super
weird
a creepy cult dude
um does he have like another another big
project that was just announced why do
people keep hiring him it's baffling
there's been all the more morbius memes
uh the jared leto superhero movie
vampire movie they got horrible reviews
absolutely bombed
it's been a whole meme
resurgence it's morbid time which is
people making fun of how dumb the movie
is well somebody at sony
thought it would be a good idea to
re-release it to
cash in on the new meme clout
and unfortunately
on its grand opening night nationwide
across the big country of the united
states with 350 million residents
friday night
prime movie time it made
eighty five thousand dollars folks
that is not good that is not a good
opening night not good
and this brings the domestic gross
revenue total
wait that seems pretty good this brings
the gross domestic revenue total to 73
million and 163 million worldwide
that that's got to be profitable right
uh
it's probably very slightly profitable
it would still be in hollywood
accounting that's that's a bomb
especially for a marvel movie
yeah 17
uh by critics and guys when you see
jared leto on something you know it's
going to be how many times do i have to
say this that joker he did was [ __ ]
unforgivable and yet you keep casting
him why are you guys doing this
can you look up the budget for more
morbius
uh yeah i was just supposed to die
actually
75 million
oh
relatively low for a comic book movie
really oh wait no hold on i don't think
that's right let me
but just yes actually yeah 75 to 83
million
so made it made money worldwide
yeah but no so the thing
with especially with big movies like
that basically whatever the film's
budget is double that
um for marketing and distribution right
they don't include that in the budget
the marketing no oh i see so also you
can almost always take whatever money it
says for the budget and nearly double
that so then they didn't make money
right and also when it says that it has
160 million
worldwide does that include like the cut
that the theaters get or is that just
gross that's the gross revenue so again
that's that's why i'm saying with like
all the
there's a lot of people
along the way that are taking a piece of
them
can you can you see how much do theaters
generally take
of an admission ticket versus the
movie maker person
you know i'm curious
i used to know this um on average movie
theater makes 45 of the revenue while
the studio makes 55 percent so a little
off from a 50 50. so if you take 55 of
160
you're looking at you know 90 million
and that's just domestic it's probably
different
internationally and then they you know
the studio has partners that are
actually doing the distribution in a lot
of other countries and so they're taking
cut and so that's that's why i say you
have to
double whatever the production so if all
that's true then they're in a massive
loss yeah that's it's a bomb for sure it
ain't more it ain't morbid
and if you compare that to dr strange
which is another marvel movie that came
around that time that made 803 million
no that's a profit there you go
is that domestic or worldwide that is
worldwide domestic 342 million
there you go
does it say how much jared leto got paid
for morbid time
sometimes that information's available
whatever it was god damn how's that guy
get at jobs
i think i would have been a better
morpheus morbius
oh yeah jared leto got in on the meme
train
his salary is not known though likely
made around the same as tom hardy played
eddie brock aka venom in the venom movie
made by the same studio already made
seven million for the first venom movie
so he's the only one that made money and
then
and the other lead actors i'm sure
here he is uh what time is it
what are you reading
nothing nothing really just
[Music]
yeah epic meme
i can't wait to show you money yeah
you're always going to let the audience
know like hey i'm in on the meme you're
not you're not making fun of me i'm in
on it he's done that with a few other
movies
the thing is like the joker there's not
many bad jokers because it's such an
interesting character there's so much to
work with i feel like
you know and everyone has put their
unique spin it really takes a horrible
actor to make the joker that bad i mean
it's a special special talent i really
truly believe that
i mean what the [ __ ] is that
oh jordan peterson's in sweden love
what's going on over there
i guess he's having some lectures over
here my friend just told me oh should
you go awesome bro i don't know about
that clean your room [ __ ]
yeah my room is messy dude yeah lean
that [ __ ] before you even go talk to
jordan i better yeah yes yes
yes
um
okay that's more of
a deal
it's morbid you know what i've got this
swedish swedish hospitality meme but
let's save that for uh
friday i guess yes
yes let's save that for friday and the
uh
philosophy discussion
yes we'll have to do it next week jordan
you're not in on this conversation
yes
this guy
he was stroking herself absent-minded oh
jesus dude get a grip her genital region
was exposed dimly
yes yes yes
[Laughter]
well guys thanks for watching this was
truly an off the rails experience i mean
name it name another podcast
yes in the whole world that can do what
we did here today name one
you can't and you never will
yes
jimmy lee
wally p
24 7
abc
tomorrow's thursday right so we'll be
here at 10 a.m yep for leftovers which
is going to be a good episode there's a
lot
a lot of insane [ __ ] to cover that's
right so it's going to be fun
and of course friday we'll be back
tomorrow at 10 a.m is the teddy fresh
drop if anyone's interested oh wally and
then just a quick announcement at the
top wally's
gofundme has passed its goal
you guys are awesome man
total sweethearts
the total is now up to
5500 we have smashed his goal
of 5 000 in just a short
amount of time you guys are you guys are
the best
love that let's see
lots of generous souls here thank you
guys so nice y'all
you know and tony's is doing really well
too which you know you guys are
sweethearts what can i say very generous
folks
here among us
thanks for the gifted subs too guys
jasper there you go
gaspar
all right see you guys tomorrow morning
you guys are gonna cut it out or what
i'm
i'm waiting
what are you waiting for
[Music]
bye